[Musique]
tous
oh
[Musique]
l'agité pour tous ce que ça rapporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs des écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse avec
difficile
[Musique]
nairobi
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 21 avril le
calendrier se dessine enfin première
étape les restrictions de déplacements
en france levée le 3 mai 2e étape la
réouverture des terrasses des commerces
non essentiel et de certains lieux de
culture autour du 15 mai le porte parole
du gouvernement le confirme emmanuel
macron annoncera lui-même les modalités
lors de la prochaine prise de parole en
russie une autre prise de parole était
attendu dans un contexte international
marqué par des tensions diplomatiques
comme chaque année vladimir poutine a
tenu son discours sur l'état de la
nation devant l'assemblée fédérale il a
notamment déploré que les attaques
contre la russie niçois devenu une sorte
de sport le président russe qui met en
garde ceux qui seraient tentés de
franchir une ligne rouge
en allemagne les députés ont adopté un
durcissement controversés de la loi anti
qu'ovide il renforce les pouvoirs du
gouvernement d'angela merkel et permet
des règles sanitaires généralisés à tout
le territoire allemand
les manifestations ont actuellement lieu
à berlin devant le parlement contre les
mesures de confinement
une victoire pour de nombreux américains
selon la famille de georgia floyd
l'ancien policier blanc d'eric cheminées
des rhodes est reconnu coupable du
meurtre de l'afro américain le juge
prononcera sa sentence dans huit
semaines avec the vines encourt douze
ans et demi de prison sa peine pourrait
être rallongée si le magistrat conclut à
l'existence de circonstances aggravantes
nous serons en direct des états unis
[Musique]
mais sur le fond du commise le rituel
est désormais immuable à un conseil de
défense sanitaire s'est tenue à l'elysée
suivi d'un conseil des ministres
si les premiers effets de mesures de
freinage a lancé en mars font sentir la
pression spital hier elle est toujours
forte dans certains territoires
malgré tout l'exécutif entend bien des
serrer la vis début mai comme prévu
on fait le point avec sl farge et stèles
ça se précise donc l'exécutif qui se
dirige vers un allègement des
restrictions et dès le 3 mai comme
annoncé commis par le président de la
république
exactement à stéphanie à commencer par
la limitation de circulation au delà de
10 kilomètres de son domicile qui
devrait être levée dès le 3 mai comme
emmanuel macron s'était engagé à le
faire fin mars lors de l'annoncé de ce
confinement hybride une levée de
restrictions qui devrait aussi
s'accompagner de la disparition de
l'attestation de déplacement l'été à ce
qu'amd elle pourrait rouvrir à lagny
mais là aussi c'était dans le calendrier
du chef de l'état gabriella talent le
porte parole du gouvernement qui a
précisé que ce dernier elle rester la
base de travail le couvre-feu quant à
lui pourrait aussi être allégée alors
doit-on le rallongés d'une heure ou
l'établir par exemple à 23h à la
question n'a pas encore été tranchée
l'animait devrait aussi être synonyme de
réouverture pour les commerces non
essentiels et les
un culturel avec des jauges de
remplissage qui pourrait varier dans les
territoires en fonction de la
circulation du virus est celle malgré ce
calendrier
la décrue de l'épidémie n'est tout de
même pas pour tout de suite
oui nous pourrions être au pic ou
proches de l'être a précisé ce matin
gabriel attal medici la levée
progressive des restrictions le
gouvernement compte sur la chute bien
entendu à des contaminations mais aussi
sur la vaccination avec cet objectif 20
millions de vaccinés et ont reçu au
moins une dose d'ici la mi-mai toujours
est il que le recul de l'épidémie doit
être confirmée car il est lent je
propose d'écouter le porte parole du
gouvernement
ce sont des résultats positifs des
résultats encourageants mais je veux le
dire des résultats encore insuffisants
d'abord à ce stade l'épidémie recule
deux fois moins rapidement qu'en
novembre c'est notamment le fait du
variant anglais nous savons qu'il est
plus contagieux plus agressif chez les
jeunes est un peu plus résistant aussi
aux mesures de freinage qui sont mises
en place
ensuite la pression hospitalière est
extrêmement forte
voilà des propos qui rejoignent ceux du
ministre de la santé dans une interview
accordée au télégramme qui évoquait une
situation fragile de son côté emmanuel
macron devrait détailler toutes les
modalités de son de ceux des confinement
dans une allocution d'ici à la mi mai
notez aussi que le premier ministre jean
castex le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et le ministre de la santé
devrait s'exprimer demain à 18 heures
lors d'une conférence de presse
oui merci et el farj en direct de
l'elysée et une levée progressive des
restrictions donc les français sont
partagés sur ce sujet écoute et que du
bonheur pour le coup de pouvoir
retrouver des amis à l'extérieur éviter
d'aller chez les uns chez les autres on
a l'impression de frôler un petit peu
quand on va voir les amis finalement et
c'est pas normal et là du coup bas
librement on va pouvoir retrouver une
vie sociale et ça c'est très cool elle
était là c'est au mois de mai non ce
serait une bonne chose parce qu'un bon
puisqu'on dit où la pandémie ça fait
quand même un an que ça dure
mon premier sentiment c'est que j'ai du
mal à y croire pour deux raisons c'est
que attend elle est quand même encore là
le virus est encore là et deuxièmement
que le gouvernement nous a annoncé ça
plusieurs fois et finalement il est je
ne dis pas que c'est sa faute mais qu'il
est obligé de reculer
maintenant si ça pose faire et ben tant
mieux
ben arous enfin reprendre un petit peu
une vie un peu plus normale et ça va me
faire du bien de revoir des amis tout ça
ça fait longtemps
et voici pour ses avis partagés l'état
en tous cas maintient son calendrier de
réouverture progressif au mois de mai
malgré une situation sanitaire toujours
fragile on l'aura compris alors le
gouvernement doit-il maintenir quoi
qu'il en coûte sur le plan sanitaire ce
calendrier est ce bien raisonnable
place à notre décryptage avec nos
invités
[Musique]
mais avec nous pour en parler nicolas
vidal éditorialistes marcel bénézet
président de la branche des cafés bars
et brasseries du syndicat ni jean
christophe qu'elle met ce vice président
du syndicat mg france médecins
généralistes également bonsoir à tous
les troy murphy messieurs d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donc a
priori un réouverture des terrasses à la
mi mai à marcel bénézet ce que c'est un
bon début où vous espériez plus
aujourd'hui nous avons une date déjà non
d'espérer le quinzaine acquis par du 17
on sait pas trop mais déjà on a une date
est ce qu'elle sera tenu je l'espère
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes plus
gouverné par les politiques mais par le
virus qui peut de jour au lendemain sur
paris bon aujourd'hui si vous voulez la
situation a l'air de s'améliorer mais ça
restait quand même difficile là les
hôpitaux tout ça donc bien sûr on veut y
croire et on espère qu'on va réouvrir
nos terrasses dès le 15 mai bien sûr
alors justement on va jeter un oeil un
petit peu plus en détail sur ces
chiffres on va les voir s'afficher l
antenne ce fameux taux d'incidence en
france 1 353 en moyenne 4 sur une
semaine pour 100000 habitants je vous
laisse regarder le détail avec tout de
même un l'ile-de-france qui est pas si
brillante que ça 556 cas sur une semaine
pour 100000 habitants on voit clairement
des disparités on va enchaîner
si vous le voulez bien avec ce chiffre
journalier déco vide 1,34 1968 nouveau
quatre copies dans 24 heures
plus de 2000 nouvelles hospitalisations
et puis de 5950 patients en réanimation
ce ne sont pas des chiffres brillants un
espace docteur qu'elle metz les chiffres
quand vous les voyez vous en tant que
médecin ces chiffres là est ce qui vous
permettent d'envisager le déconfinement
prévue à la mi mai par le gouvernement
on était inquiet quand on voit ces
chiffres on est inquiet parce qu'ils
correspondent effectivement le porte
pendant ladite on a une décrue lente les
plus lente que prévu de décontamination
parce que le mariage gay est extrêmement
contagieux et on sait par ailleurs
qu'elles variant brésilien aussi qui est
là qui ne se développe pas parce que
lorient
prend toute la place et on sait pas très
bien ce qui va se passer alors si vous
demandez aux médecins que je suis si les
échéances gouvernementales vont être
tenues je suis bien en peine pour
répondre parce que vraiment on sait pas
ce que va faire l'épidémie et c'est le
problème de cette épidémie c'est que
depuis le début on court après mais
c'est très difficile de dire vas
décompte final quelle date on va ouvrir
des bars alors en même temps le
gouvernement et c'est pour ça qu'il est
là prend ses décisions en fonction
d'autres critères que les critères
médicaux qui sont les critères
économiques et des critères sociaux je
comprends tout à fait que le
représentant des des restaurants qui est
avec nous et très envie de revoir les
terrasses ouvrir et je comprends tout à
fait que les gens aussi est très envie
de sortir mais on a ce virus qui est là
qui l'a qui est très présent dans une
vaccination qui avance mais qui avance
un peu trop doucement est vraiment le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est la vaccination
en fait tout ce qu'on peut sur le
terrain pour vacciner nos hôpitaux sont
saturés je crois que c'est ça le critère
c'est le taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation
on fait tout pour éviter que tout
n'explose et donc on est dans cet
équilibre précaire entre la chaîne des
du confinement et des le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation qui
la vaccination sur le terrain
c'est cet équilibre là qui est difficile
à trouver c'est pour ça que prédire
aujourd'hui qu'on va absolument réouvrir
début et ça me paraît faire preuve d'un
grand optimisme
moi franchement je ne sais pas ce qui va
se passer début mai en tout cas nous
gouvernement semble vouloir tenir ses
promesses nicolas vidal quand on entend
le docteur elle mais c'est quand on
entend le porte parole du gouvernement
on se dit que la décision d' emmanuel
macron elle sera forcément politique le
docteur nous disait basée sur des
critères économiques et sociaux mais
enfin aussi sur du politique on rappelle
que dans un an il ya la présidentielle
emmanuel macron est en quelque sorte
acculé à produire de bons résultats à
satisfaire et français je vous apporte
un décryptage politique effectivement
j'entends ce que dit le docteur est la
raison il ya une situation préoccupante
et si la décision du manioc le maquereau
qui est compliqué aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est dans une impasse emmanuel
macron parce que il a annoncé cette date
du 15 mai et très sincèrement c'était
beaucoup trop
donc tu eu mais pourquoi il a avancé et
on l'a déjà dit sur le plateau
finalement il ya des réseaux sociaux il
ya aussi l'idée sociale de ceux de ce
casse mais les gens n'en peuvent plus
les gens vivent dans une camisole
sanitaires on comprendre que l'épidémie
épidémie il est encore très haute dans
les chiffres
c'est un truc mais les gens n'en peuvent
plus aujourd'hui et emmanuel macron il
s'est tellement avancé sur le 15 mai
qu'aujourd'hui comment voulez vous
qu'ils reculent pour moi très
sincèrement il a même pas un de ces
quatres sociale dans les mains emmanuel
macron il a décidé de fermer il va
décider de rouvrir ou pas d'ailleurs
envoyé il ya des espoirs des espoirs qui
sont un peu douchés on a tous envie bien
entendu de reprendre une vie normale
emmanuel macron il s'est mis dans une
situation de très dangereuses on nous a
dit qu'il y avait des talents mêlant
d'épidémiologistes mais on va voir
effectivement le case mais s'il va pas
être obligé de reculer emmanuel macron
hélas il recul qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce que les gens on va accepter
effectivement de rester encore un mois
ou deux semaines trois semaines dans une
camisole sanitaires ça c'est la vraie
question est très sincèrement j'aimerais
pas être à la place d'emmanuel macway je
pense je le redis qui s'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup avancé manuel mâcon là
dessus marcel bénézet vous on le disait
un vous représentez les cafés les bars
et les brasseries quel est l'état
d'esprit de la profession parce que pour
l'instant on vous a entendu ici ou là
mais mais pas tant que ça il n'y a pas
eu une vraie révolte aujourd'hui
clairement vous attendez que le
gouvernement tienne ses promesses ou
quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan
sanitaire vous seriez prêt
éventuellement à accepter un autre délai
ou pas du tout c'est pas dans l'état
d'esprit
aujourd'hui je pense que la pole à la
profession n'en peut plus mais je pense
aussi que la société n'en peut plus
comme le disait tout à l'heure notre
d'intervenants des gens sens où une
cabine d'une camisole ils n'en peuvent
plus aujourd'hui on a deux en a trois
problèmes
on a le problème de l'épidémie qui est
important on a le problème économique
est aussi important d'un problème
psychologique
aujourd'hui un problème psychologique
énorme aujourd'hui vous avez des gens
qui sont au bord de la dépression
comment on va ressortir de cette
situation de covile on va sortir c'est
que ce soit la population les
commerçants bien sûr avec des crédits
qui n'en peuvent plus avec avec des
remboursements qui peut pas assumer
aujourd'hui la situation est très
compliquée je vous assure que je ne sais
pas comment on va sortir de ces deux
mais cette date du 15 mai on y tient
bien sûr cognitive parce que ça va être
une bouffée
c'est une étude
où est jeté à la mer on va tâcher le
pjak rocher voilà docteur ken metz quand
vous entendez autre ami qui représente 1
les cafés les brasseries les restaurants
vous ça vous fait peur en tant que
docteur où vous vous dis bon c'est pas
la pire des situations les terrasses
ouvertes on a vu qu'en espagne a priori
ça provoquait pas dans plus de deux-
catastrophe les restaurants en plein air
oui tout dépend des mesures de 6 en
session qui sont faites on peut penser
effectivement qu'en plein air et avec
une distance respecter ça pour éviter
les contaminations mais ces études là
sont faites avec une épidémie cancun est
un virus qu'on connaît de lerus bouge le
virus mute
on a vu que le vieil de lorient anglais
tu puis contagieux que le variant
précédent on sait pas ce que feront les
autres orient parce qu'il y en aura
d'autres
il faut pas se leurrer et donc
franchement je moi je peux pas dire ça
je mais je comprends tout à fait je
soigne les restaurateurs je peux vous
dire que effectivement ils sont détresse
mais qui est beaucoup de gens des 13 ans
pays et donc on est face à un choix
politique comme l'a dit notre
intervenant politique qui est de choisir
voilà on choisit entre le sanitaire
l'économique le social c'est le show qui
est extrêmement difficile
si vous me demandez mon avis de médecin
je voyais qu'on verra le début mai pour
voir où en année et on décidera en
fonction il n'y a pas que le critère
médical et c'est ça tout le problème du
gouvernement il n'y a pas que les
critères médicale nicolas vidal est ce
que ce n'est pas pire de prendre la
décision de déconfit nez et de tenir en
l'occurrence des promesses peut-être
intenable sur le plan sanitaire et
d'être là on imagine le pire vous parlez
tous deux de marion qui font peur d'être
obligé de dirt confiné ensuite ce serait
pire coteaux bien entendu c'est pire que
tout sur la question qu'il faut se poser
vous regardez emmanuel macron le en même
temps il quoi qu'il en coûte
la question c'est qui ça va coûter à qui
ça va coûter effectivement soit de
continuer à faire du confinement ou ne
s'est pas une liberté régulier ce
curieux concept de la liberté régulier
de la liberté encadrée ou sk qui ça va
coûter sur le plan sanitaire
c'est toute la question aujourd'hui mais
la réalité aujourd'hui ce pays c'est que
les gens dont je le répète les gens n'en
peuvent absolument plus on imagine les
restaurateurs et les cafetiers
les commerces on est essentielle ce beau
mot de commerce on est essentielle et
aujourd'hui je le redis emmanuel macron
il ya un mur face à lui il est obligé de
choisir et là on est vraiment dans le
choix politique et il sait très bien
emmanuel macron bien entendu que il
risque d'avoir une explosion sociale
et ça je crois qu'il a la conscience
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça qu'il est
maintenant obligé de donner une
perspective la perspective à titre
individuel ou à titre collectif c'est
absolument important et vous vous pouvez
pas un moment donné entraver la liberté
des gens en permanence je parle de
camisoles sanitaires même s'il ya des
recours sur sur l'épidémie bien entendu
il ya des risques
on est tous d'accord on est tous
conscients de ça mais à un moment donné
on peut pas enfermer un pays comme ça
vous avez les bars des angles fermi ce
toute une série de gens comme ça
après moi je ne suis pas médecin c'est
pas mon boulot moi c'est mon notre
décryptage politique
emmanuel macron il se trouve dans une
situation il vous l'avez dit stéphanie
ya effectivement la présidentielle qui
dans un an et ça va lui coûter très cher
emmanuel macron quoi qu'il en coûte ces
présidentielles mais vous savez
finalement le en même temps il a
beaucoup limité aujourd'hui c'est plus
le temps du en même temps il faudra
choisir
il va falloir trancher et gouverner
c'est choisir alors le nerf de la guerre
évidemment le sait c'est la vaccination
pour le moment pas d'autre issue qui
semble crédible
regardez ces chiffres au 21 avril 1 19%
de la population seulement en france qui
a reçu au moins une dose soit 12
millions et demi de personnes 4 millions
ennemis un peu plus 1 68 million de
personnes ont reçu deux doses docteur
c'est pas brillant on affiche ces
chiffres comme une communication
quotidiennement fin par rapport au
royaume uni et en israël
on est vraiment dans les fraises si
j'ose dire familièrement emmanuel macron
ça le met forcément dans une impasse
parce que quand boris johnson nous
annonçait enfin l'a annoncé et au
royaume uni un calendrier c'était qu'il
y avait un succès à côté de de la
campagne de vaccination c'est pas notre
cas alors si c'est pas tout à fait vrai
c'est même s'il est un peu fou on est
dans le peloton où on est on est moyen
va dire on est dans la moyenne
européenne pour la vaccination
bon il sonne et pas loin de la moyenne
non plus parce que quand il annonce les
chiffres il a dans ce sens fait il
précise pas que si c'est une dose et
lorsqu'on compare la vaccination à une
dose se perçoit coni pas si mal alors on
vaccine à tour de bras mais pas assez
vite je suis bien d'accord
il ne faudrait plus de vaccins bon c'est
un problème mondial c'est un problème
européen en particulier et c'est aussi
un problème lié à l'astra d'astra
aujourd'hui pour le mois de mai mois
d'avril c'est 500 mille doses pour le
mois de mai c'est un million trois cent
mille doses de prévu et on sait qu'ils
désaffection de l'astra qui nous pose
problème parce que dans le même temps
donc si les gens ne se font pas vacciner
avec d'astrazeneca
alors là ce tracé des cas je comprends
pas ce qui s'est passé un très
honnêtement c'est donc un vaccin à la
dune au virus qui est très décrié en
france lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres
lorsqu'on parle de façon très simple il
ya eu dans le monde sur l'astra 469
thrombose et 191 en europe ce qui est un
chiffre normal par rapport au trombone
ce qui serait une façon naturelle ont
grandi à papus de thrombose dans la
population qui ne se vaccinent pas que
dans la population qui se vaccinent par
contre on a eu quelques accidents
exceptionnel 18 cas avec des accidents
très graves thrombose cérébrale ce qu'on
appelle ses idées donc pas ces détails
mais ce sont des choses très très grave
donc on a eu 25 ha sur deux millions de
vaccins autrement dit un cas par million
si on relativise ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que vous avez à peu près les
mêmes chances de mourir à cause
astrazeneca que cela nous faire
foudroyer en marchant dans
rues de votre ville voilà il faut quand
même relativiser donc il n'ya pas de sur
risque avec astra je pense qu'il faut le
redire mais on constate une désaffection
l'astra une faune tenir compte et donc
il faut augmenter la production de
vaccins à arn donc les files heures et
les modernes on va augmenter cette
production et en particulier mal
augmenté à partir du mois d'août et
septembre alors les doses progresser
très vite mais c'est déjà un peu tard
moi j'aimerais que en plus avec ciné
beaucoup plus vite beaucoup plus vite
parce que la solution encore une fois
elle est dans la vaccination est la
solution je crains pas de dire elle est
aussi dans cette fois nous passeport
vaccinale on nous promet alors il ya des
gens qui crient à la privation de
liberté franchement c'est pas parce
qu'on va sortir notre application des
copies de notre papier disant qu'on est
bien vaccinés pour aller au cinéma que
c'est une atteinte intolérable à la
liberté il faut arrêter de dire des
bêtises moi aussi ça me permet d'aller
au cinéma ou des les bords en coin
terrasse ou dans ce restaurant
j'aurais bien content d'avoir mon
attestation qui cohabitent donc sinon on
vaccine l'accident mais pour ça il faut
que nous ayons bellows on va en parler
dans quelques instants avec notre ami
brasseur à monsieur bénézet sur ce
passeport sanitaire voir s'il est
d'accord mais avant tout sur l'astra
zeneca je voudrais vous faire écouter
justement emmanuel macron qui a bien
conscience 5 de cette désaffection des
difficultés pour convaincre malgré tous
nos citoyens sur l'astra zenjov qui est
une problématique à laquelle là on doit
collectivement réfléchir en termes de
communication et de capacité à
convaincre
alors nicolas vidal la communication sur
astrazeneca nos confrères du figaro nous
murmure que jean castex a même suggéré
que sheila se fassent vacciner pour
inciter les plus de 55 ans voilà en
france qui douteraient de l'astra zé
meka phare en dit long sur la
communication petit peu laborieuse du
gouvernement vous avez vu mon rictus
stéphanie vous avez vu mon rictus et
comme jean michel blanquer requis
aujourd'hui jouer à la marelle et
faisait pierre caillou ciseaux dans une
école au centre de loisirs c'est pareil
ils n'ont plus que la communication
c'est absolument terrible cette histoire
là la réalité cette histoire de
vaccination cofor coup pour ou contre
c'est qu'on a prêté allégeance à l'union
européenne pour ce produit pour produire
finalement pour les acheter il faut
qu'on bouge et la becquée vaccinale bien
entendu même en terme de logistique a
énormément de problèmes alors on nous
dit en permanence oui ça va accélérer sa
va accélérer sa va accélérer mais les
semaines passent les mois pas si ça
n'accélère pas ses salars et inamical
également en hivernants la soirée n'est
qu'il faut communiquer pour comble qu'on
est d'accord c'est ce que nous disait le
docteur calmès on ad astra zeneca des
doses qu'on jette par centaines tous les
soirs en france parce que il ya une
défiance on a mal communiqué c'est aussi
la responsabilité du gouvernement
alors peut-être dessus mais moi je pense
aussi une liberté individuelle à se
faire vacciner ou pas ça c'est
extrêmement important on peut pas
forcément obligé les gens sur vacciner
après si le gouvernement veut
communiquer là dessus qu'ils
communiquent très bien pour lui mais je
crois qu'au moment donné il ya une
liberté à se faire vacciner ou pas alors
qu'on peut parler du pass and literature
mais moi j'en appelle à la liberté de
chacun de se faire vacciner ne pas se
faire vacciner me semble-t-il c'est un
droit absolu et individuels à chacun
voilà ce que je peux répondre vraiment
cette idée là si le gouvernement
communiqué aujourd'hui il ne fit que
communiqué du gouvernement
marcel bénézet justement sur cette
question du passé ni terre le docteur no
10 et voilà c'est très bien si ça peut
nous permettre de retourner au
restaurant au cinéma vous en tant que
représentant des brasseurs des cafetiers
quelle est votre opinion
alors nous tous qui sera bon pour faire
vivre les gens normalement on est
preneur
même moi je suis vacciné à l'astral
délicat et je suis pas marié juin cours
live il devant vaud mais non tout ce qui
sera bon pour pour faire pour favoriser
la la clientèle à revenir chez nous on
le fera si moi j'ai envie d'aller au
cinéma jeux sortis demoiselle bons
moments passés veille sanitaire
non nous tous qui ce qui est bon à
prendre le prend pour que les gens
puissent eux ressortir en toutes celles
tranquillité et en toute sécurité
nous on est preneurs de tout ça donc
on veut retrouver sa liberté et nos
clients aussi nous attendre en lice ils
sont ils sont ravis de le retrouver
docteur qu'elle metz il ya évidemment
vous en avait parlé
7ce danger en ce spectre des variants
est ce que c'est
c'est ce sujet qui va tout faire capoter
selon vous la question des variants
brésilien on voit que la france a pris
les mêmes restrictions concernant le
variant indien ça suffira à stopper ces
dangereux variant il va falloir
s'habituer à vivre avec le co vide
le coc vide et toutes ses formes et tous
ces brillants qui vont se succéder très
probablement c'est pour ça qu'on a
vraiment que la vaccination pour se
sortir de là parce que ça va évoluer en
aura d'autres comme il est probable qu
on me dira au mois de septembre
il faut vacciner avec le nouveau vaccin
arn qui prend en compte tels et tels
variant il provoque comme la grippe
chaque année il faudra qu'on soit
vacciné je dis pas que ça va arriver à
me dis que c'est probable cette épidémie
est maintenant une pandémie qui touche
au nombre incroyable de genre je vois
mal comment le s'arrêterait surtout que
bon on maxime des occidentaux parce
qu'ils ont les moyens de ces pays des
vaccins mais il en reste et des
réservoirs des pays africains des pays
indiens etc qui eux n'ont pas forcément
les moyens de l'accident ma soeur
population et qu'il voit des réservoirs
à virus dont nous ne faisons pas
d'illusions on va devoir vivre avec la
machination et c'est pour ça que la
question de la réouverture de l'activité
économique et cetera se pose et c'est
pour ça que la question de la
vaccination et si si l'aigu je veux dire
il faut vraiment qu'on vaccine les gens
rapidement ont retrouvé une vie normale
dans un contexte de pandémie
merci en tout cas à tous les trois
docteurs jean christophe calmès marcel
bénézet nicolas vidal d'avoir été avec
nous d'avoir accepté ce décryptage en
direct
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partons
poutine le président russe qui a tenu
son discours sur l'état de la nation
il a notamment regretté que les attaques
contre la russie se multiplient et puis
direction ensuite l'allemagne où les
députés ont adopté un durcissement
controversés de la loi anti qu'ovide il
renforce les pouvoirs du gouvernement
merkel et permet des règles sanitaires
généralisés à tout le territoire
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
il
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisqu'on est temps de dire est qu'il y
a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
un certain regain de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts même
les citoyens on est une société qui est
tellement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde vivre
avec la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi là bas est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême serre est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un guillaume ac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière les pères mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vue il ya une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
baptiste et pour tout ce que ça apporte
aux enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à la dgre au poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire mais c'est pénalisant
pour l'enfant pour leurs familles on
oublie les parents qui sont responsables
du foyer est temps que les parents ne
maîtrise et ne parlent pas le français à
la maison basse avec difficile
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez en
russie l'exercice est désormais annuel
valdimir poutine s'est exprimé ce matin
devant les deux chambres du parlement le
gouvernement et les gouvernements
gouverneurs régionaux
l'occasion de dresser le bilan de
l'année écoulée et d'annoncer les grands
axes de sa politique pour l'année à
venir
mais dans un contexte de tensions
croissantes avec l'occident son discours
était très attendu
compte-rendu depuis moscou avec vera
goffman 78 minutes au lieu d'une heure
le discours de vladimir poutine a
surtout porté sur la sphère sociale et
la politique intérieure comme il l'avait
annoncé quelques jours avant son
intervention le sujet clé était
évidemment la pandémie de coronavirus je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait de son
intervention la vaccination revêt une
importance primordiale je demande tous
les dirigeants les dirigeants de régions
de d'être préoccupés par ce problème
la vaccination doit être universel pour
avoir accès à notre communauté
collective
cela ne dépend que nous de nous tous de
tous les citoyens s'il vous plaît encore
une fois je vous demande et j'appelle
tous les citoyens russes et s'il vous
plaît vaccinez vous la société les
citoyens et l'état ont agi de façon
responsable et avec toute la solidarité
elle nous avons anticipé les événements
nous avons diminuer les risques de
contamination nous avons fourni aux
médecins et aux citoyens les moyens de
protection après une heure
d'intervention vladimir poutine a passé
à la politique internationale et l'a
souligné que la russie avait ses propres
intérêts qu'elle n'allait pas hésité à
défendre le président ont déploré que
les attaques contre la russie soit
devenu une sorte de sport écoutez nous
avons nos propres intérêts
et bien sûr il ya des intérêts que nous
protégeons dans le cadre du droit
international comme les autres pays le
font
il ya des gestes hostile vis-à-vis de la
russie et qui ne cessent pas certains
pays ont déjà cette habitude insolite de
saisir toute occasion et même sans
occasion d'attaquer la russie c'est une
sorte de sport nous allons déterminer
nous mêmes les lignes rouges dans les
relations avec chaque pays a déclaré le
président russe
en cas d'agression la réponse dure
rapide et asymétrique
écoutez si quelqu'un perd soient nos
bonnes intentions comme indifférence ou
comme notre faiblesse et qui voudrait
quand même faire exploser ou bien brûler
ses ponts il doit savoir que la réponse
de la russie pourrait être asymétrique
est bien dur nous avons beaucoup de
tolérance eu beaucoup de responsabilités
de professionnalisme et de certitudes
dans notre véracité et le bon sens quand
nos emprunts entreprenons certaine
mesure
j'espère que personne ne va franchir
cette ligne rouge et nos allons
déterminer ses lignes rouges
dans un cas concret et nous allons le
faire nous mêmes
vladimir poutine a terminé sur une note
conciliante en invitant la communauté
internationale à discuter de la
stabilité stratégique et mondiale et à
créer un environnement sans conflits nés
au moment où vladimir poutine prononcé
son discours des manifestations non
autorisées en soutien alexeï navalni se
dérouler dans plusieurs villes russes la
police a procédé à plusieurs
arrestations ont rejoint moscou notre
correspondante one claireaux bonsoir
antoine y at il du monde sur place
mais en fait ça dépend d'où on se trouve
en effet depuis le début de la soirée
policiers et manifestants jouent un peu
au chat et à la souris en effet le lieu
initial le l'initiale de réunion devait
être la place du manège mais celle-ci
ayant été complètement bouclée par les
forces de l'ordre les manifestants en
forme et via la chaîne télégramme des
organisateurs de cette manifestation
ce sont donc retournés vers un autre
lieu puis un troisième puis un quatrième
est à chaque fois la police ayant un
temps d'avancé elle empêché les
manifestants de se retrouver dans un
seul et même endroit sur une place
dégagés afin de voir un petit peu le les
effectifs le monde qui est venu pour
cette manifestation malgré tout le
ministère russe de l'intérieur a
comptabilisé environ 6000 manifestants à
moscou quatre mille cinq cents à saint
pétersbourg ou encore 1000 à
novossibirsk pour un total sur le sur
l'ensemble du territoire russe estimée à
14 mille quatre cents manifestants
d'après les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur
il ya également eu des inter des
interpellations ici à moscou une
vingtaine dont la secrétaire de presse
d'alexey ne va ni antoine quel est
l'état de santé n'avait que ça une
avanie
eh bien depuis qu'il a été incarcéré
dans cette colonie pénitentiaire de la
région de vladimir il s'est plaint de
mal récurrent au dos son entourage
estime qu'il souffre d'une double hernie
discale
il est donc durant le temps le début de
son interview de son nom dans son
incarcération il a demandé à avoir accès
à des soins qui selon lui lui ont été
refusées c'est pour cette raison qu'il
s'est mis qu'il a entamé cette grève de
la faim depuis le 31 mars dernier cela
fait déjà trois semaines
son état de santé s'est donc dégradé à
causeur en partie de cette grève de la
faim et c'est pour cette raison que son
entourage ses avocats estiment que
désormais sa vie est en danger
alors c'est pour cette raison que cette
manifestation a été appelée aujourd'hui
mais il faut savoir qu'il y a tout juste
deux jours les autorités pénitentiaires
l'ont transféré vers un hôpital toujours
un hôpital pénitentiaire également afin
qu'ils soient prises en charge en raison
de son état de santé
merci antoine gayraud en direct de
moscou
mais en allemagne est présent
manifestation anti confinement la police
a fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes pour
disperser plusieurs milliers de
protestataires réunis dans la capitale
berlin il dénonce les mesures de
restriction en même temps les députés
allemands ont adopté une modification
controversé qui renforce les pouvoirs du
gouvernement d'angela merkel pour durcir
la lutte contre la troisième vague de la
pandémie
les précisions de peter oliver notre
correspondant onde verte et
international à berlin fait la loi sur
la protection contre les infections a
été adopté par le bundestag et mercredi
cela n'a pas été facile
elle est passée avec 342 voix pour 250
voix contre et 60 4 abstentions
opposition à l'amendement venait de tout
le spectre politique l'opposition
d'extrême droite
l'alternative pour l'allemagne
et l'opposition d'extrême gauche die
linke ont dit non le parti libéral
démocrate ne l'a pas soutenu les verts
qui enregistre d'énormes avancées dans
les sondages en amont des élections du
bundestag en automne se sont abstenus la
controverse et est inévitable car cette
loi signifie que les dirigeants des
régions perdent des compétences au
profit du gouvernement fédéral à berlin
ses compétences permet trois angela
merkel veut dire non plus voici ce que
vous devriez faire
s'agissant de restriction contre locaux
vitis 9 mai voici ce que vous allez
faire dans toute l'allemagne
il y a encore une chance que la loi soit
bloquée par la chambre haute du
parlement allemand jeudi
mais cela semble peu probable on sait
déjà cependant que cet amendement sera
contestée devant la cour
constitutionnelle allemande des membres
du parti libéral démocrate ont déclaré
avoir déjà préparé une objection et
souhaitait la présenter aussi rapidement
que possible
cela est considéré comme nécessaire car
peu importe comment tourner la chose
l'approchent régional n'a pas sanctionné
le virus ne s'arrête pas aux frontières
entre les états allemands ne se
préoccupa d'où il se trouve qu'il
contamine la gestion du coc vite 19 en
allemagne et est très fragmenté
certains états ont mis en place des
confidences et d'autres ont assuré les
règles alors même que le govic 19
circuler à très haut niveau dans leur
région certains dirigeants locaux
il faut le dire ont même fait de la
politique avec le virus
pour certains dirigeants de régions
c'était l'occasion de dire qu'ils
avaient tenu bon face à la chancelière
angela merkel face au gouvernement
fédéral à berlin
même si cela a permis à certains
politiques de gagner un minimum de
popularité auprès de certains électeurs
cela n'a pas vraiment contribué à la
lutte contre le virus en allemagne et
outre rend toujours le plan de relance
européen reprend des couleurs et pour
cause la cour constitutionnelle
allemande a donné son feu vert à sa
ratification rejetant un recours qui
contestait notamment le mécanisme inédit
et controversé de dette commune pour en
parler nous sommes années claude
blanchemaison bonsoir blanc expert en
relations internationales tout d'abord
pourquoi cette décision de la cour
constitutionnelle allemande était
attendu ben elle était très attendue
parce que comme vous venez de lire c est
un préalable à la ratification par
l'allemagne de ce plan de relance dans
lequel la chancelière merkel avait
dépensé beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de
savoir faire et il était très attaché si
la cour constitutionnelle de karlsruhe
avait décidé aujourd'hui que ce plan
n'était pas conforme à la constitution
eh bien ça aurait été la fin de ce plan
et la fin du plan de relance européen
par conséquent un gros échec pour madame
merkel à trois mois d'élections qui vont
probablement amené un nouveau chancelier
une nouvelle chancelière puisque madame
merkel n'est pas candidate
donc l'enjeu était très important
politiquement pour le gouvernement
allemand est aujourd'hui la voie est
ouverte
18 pays ont ratifié ce plan les autres
vont suivre
peut-être y aura-t-il encore quelques
difficultés avec la hongrie et
la pologne mais on a on a l'habitude et
madame merkel à chaque fois a réussi à
surmonter ses difficultés avec ces deux
pays qui ne veulent pas que l'on
conditionne l'octroi de crédits à des
conditions de respect des droits de
l'homme
donc on a fait un progrès considérable
puisque avec cette ce plan la commission
est autorisé à lever un emprunt de 500
milliards d'euros
et c'est la première fois que la
commission est autorisée afin à lever un
emprunt sur le marché des capitaux et en
deuxième lieu le deuxième la deuxième
percée c'est le fait que les états
percevront des concours de ce fonds en
fonction de leurs besoins tels qu'ils
ont été établis en fonction de leur
population en fonction des dommages
causés par le kobe 19 et qu' ils
rembourseront avec un très grand différé
près de vingt ans de différé en fonction
de leurs clés budgétaire
c'est donc en effet une mise en commun
d'une partie de la dette des états
membres c'est donc une percée tout à
fait importante et c'était inimaginable
il ya un peu plus d'un an
alors claude quand la france parce que
c'est la question évidemment c'est ce
que vous pouvez attendre quand est ce
que la france va-t-elle profiter de ce
plan de relance âprement négocié alors
le plan tel qu'il a été négocié prévoir
ce que les enveloppes dont bénéficieront
les divers états membres en fonction de
critères comme je viens de l'indiquer et
la france s'attend donc à recevoir 40
milliards d'euros au cours des années et
2021 et 2022
mais évidemment ça n'est pas un guichet
ouvert chaque état membre a été prié
d'élaborer un plan un plan de réforme un
plan d'action un plan d'investissement
et chacun de ses plans a fait l'objet de
discussions à bruxelles et le plan
français était présente et a été
approuvé en deuxième lieu compte tenu de
l'urgence
les états membres seront autorisés à
engager les dépenses sur ses plans
d'investissements
sur ces actions qui ont été approuvés à
bruxelles
quitte à attendre pour se faire
rembourser que le plan serait totalement
mis en place parce que sur le sur le
plan des garanties juridiques et
financières faites un petit peu
compliqué à mettre en place et que la
commission doit aussi répondre de
contrôle de la cour des comptes
européenne et d'un certain nombre de
contrôleurs financiers
donc ça prendra un petit peu de temps je
pense que le conseil européen du 24 juin
se prononcera sur ce sujet demandera une
accélération de la mise en place
concrète et se penchera peut-être sur
les deux premiers le dernier problèmes
résiduels et puis il est possible aussi
que la chancelière pour qui ce sera l'un
des derniers conseils européens voudra
marquer encore une fois l'histoire de
l'europe en disant que ça n'est
peut-être pas suffisant on verra l
europe sa gestion des vaccins a quelque
peu écorné son image son plan sera utile
lui suffisant pour faire face aux
conséquences économiques de la pandémie
alors effectivement si on compare aux
états unis ça fait un petit peu modeste
puisque joe biden a fait approuver le
mois dernier un premier plan de relance
qui se monte à 1900 milliards de dollars
donc ça fait à peu près 1500 milliards
d'euros mais c'est en effet à peu près
le double du plan du plan européen
cela dit pour faire une comparaison
équitable il faudrait ajouter au plan
européen
les plans de relance purement nationaux
qui ont été mises en place ou qui sont
en train d'être mise en place
mais cela dit les américains aussi ont
d'autres plans pour les infrastructures
qui sont actuellement discutées par le
congrès est en effet la relance
américaine est beaucoup plus massive que
ce qui se fait en europe
donc c'est un premier un plus premières
critiques que l'on peut faire peut-être
que l'europe ne voit pas assez grand
mais il fallait créer des instruments
qui sont maintenant créer en effet le
conseil européen fin juin peut tout à
fait décider qu'il faut aller plus loin
dans cette direction ou en avant à nîmes
jean ans d'autres procédures pour ce qui
est des vaccins et bien l'europe et est
victime du fait qu' il y à peu des
usines de fabrication de vaccins sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
après tout beaucoup de ses capacités
industrielles sont en dehors du
territoire de l'union européenne
et il y en a trop peu il faut l'on prend
à porter deuxième élément c'est que les
états membres ont sans doute été trop
timide trop respectueux de l'accord
politique il avait passé pour se
coordonner à bruxelles mais l'union
européenne en tant que telle n'a pas de
compétence sanitaire elle à celle que
des états membres veulent bien lui
conférer par consensus et rien empêché
les états membres certains l'ont
d'ailleurs fait d'acheter des vaccins
en plus des dotations européenne de les
acheter sur le marché mondial partout et
de faire homologuer ces vaccins par
leurs propres autorités sanitaires
nationales
en attendant qu'ils le ce qu'elle le
soit par l'autorité européenne des
médicaments
c'est notamment le cas pour les vaccins
russe puisque certains états membres
souhaitent les utiliser tout de suite
sans même attendre l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
merci claude blanchemaison d'avoir été
avec nous ailleurs en europe au danemark
son est fini des restrictions le pays
retrouve une vie presque normale après
plus de quatre mois de mesures
sanitaires pour lutter contre la
pandémie un test négatif ou une
attestation de vaccination est néanmoins
à rocky pour profiter des restaurants et
magasins plus revient en perd le goût de
la vie d'après les danois peuvent enfin
le savourer à partir de ce mercredi le
danemark ce confinement allégé depuis le
mois de décembre a décidé de lever les
restrictions sanitaires avant la fin mai
date initialement prévue
les restaurants les commerces ou encore
les salles de sport peuvent donc
accueillir leurs clients
seule condition pour dîner à l'intérieur
le corona passe application qui permet
d'attester de la vaccination contre le
coït 19 ou d'un test pcr négatif de -2 3
jours
j'ai juste subi un test rapide hier afin
que nous puissions réservés parce qu'on
a besoin d'être testé pour pouvoir
manger à l'intérieur on peut s'asseoir à
l'extérieur son test mais si on veut
manger à l'intérieur on doit avoir un
test aujourd'hui on se sent soulagé
enthousiaste heureux c'est juste une
journée fantastique et nous sommes
impatients que ce soit espérons le tout
à fait complet ce soir c'est bon d'être
ouverts pour retourner dans les écoles
les entreprises les centres commerciaux
ou encore les salons de tatouage
les danois doivent se munir d'un test
pcr négative de moins de trois jours je
pense que nous avons fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour faire fonctionner notre
société et si cela coûte un petit est un
petit coton dans la bouche pendant deux
secondes
nous le ferons tous donc oui nous sommes
opérationnels et nous en sommes heureux
grâce à une campagne de dépistage
intensive et régulière le danemark
entame comme le royaume uni sa vie
d'après prochaine étape vacciner tous
les danois de plus de 16 ans avant la
fin du mois de juillet au mexique pour
la première fois depuis un an des
écoliers sont retournés dans les salles
de classe ce lundi une rentrée dans le
respect des règles sanitaires les
enseignants ont été vaccinées en tant
que groupes prioritaires dans un pays
qui compte déjà deux cent douze mille
quatre cent soixante six morts et
dominion plus de 2 millions 300 mille
car depuis le début de la pandémie ont
fait le point avec leila sarah dans le
sud est du pays sur la côte mexicaine du
golfe l'état de comme péché a été le
moins touché par la pandémie
c'est ici que des élèves retrouvent
l'école en petits groupes pour maintenir
la distanciation physique
la recommandation est d'avoir quatre
élèves dans chaque salle ici il n'y en
aura que trois quarts c'est en fonction
du nombre d'élèves par classe je vais
les répartir selon les priorités
scolaire de chacun face à des
enseignants vacciner les écoliers
portent des masques et des écrans
faciaux en plastique
la durée des cours est néanmoins
raccourcis je suis contente d'aller à
l'école de voir ma maîtresse et mes
copains de classe
je parle un peu sur internet mais je ne
peux pas travailler car le réseau ne
fonctionne pas très bien
des travaux scolaires ont été envoyés
aux écoliers depuis le début de la
pandémie
mais ils sont nombreux à ne pas avoir
d'ordinateur ou d'accès internet à la
maison
ce n'est pas la même chose ici pour nous
nous ne sommes presque jamais à la
maison
nous devons aller aux champs nous devons
travailler nous n'avons pas assez de
temps pour faire court maintenant nous
sommes heureux parce qu'elle va à
l'école pas à plein temps mais elle va
apprendre plus de choses là bas
la campagne de vaccination des
enseignants de cinq autres états ayant
un nombre relativement faible de k2
coronavirus a commencé ce mardi jour
choisi par le président mexicain andres
manuel lopez obrador pour se faire
injecter sa première dose du vaccin
d'oxford astrazeneca
aux etats-unis est présent le verdict
tant attendu a été rendu à minneapolis
après trois semaines de procès vers
écurie n'a été déclaré coupable du
meurtre de georgia floyd cet
afro-américain asphyxié lors d'une
interpellation l'année dernière le juge
prononcera sa sentence dans huit
semaines
valentin garanties nous le jury en ce
qui concerne le premier chef
d'accusation meurtre non intentionnel au
second degré déclarons l'accusé coupable
nous le jury aux chefs d'accusation de
meurtre troisième degré perpétrant un
acte éminemment dangereux déclarons
l'accusé coupable nous le jury en ce qui
concerne le troisième chef d'accusation
homicide involontaire au second degré
négligence coupable création d' un
risque déraisonnable déclarons l'accusé
coupable moins d'une journée
c'est ce qui aura suffi au jury pour
délibérer et jugé coupable des règles
chauvine de meurtre au deuxième et
troisième degré et d'homicide
involontaire
soit toutes les charges retenues contre
lui menotté puis écroué dès la
délibération l'ex policier de 45 ans
encourt douze ans et demi de prison
mais pourrait voir sa peine allongées si
le juge conclut à l'existence de
circonstances aggravantes pour la
famille de georges floyd c'est un vrai
soulagement
aujourd'hui nous pouvons à nouveau
respirer
je me sens soulagé d'avoir enfin la
possibilité d'espérer dormir un peu j'ai
dit que j'avais la fois qu'il sera
condamné
à l'image de la famille c'est toute une
partie des états unis qui a accueilli
cette décision avec joie des scènes de
liesse ont eu lieu dans plusieurs villes
notamment devant le tribunal de
minneapolis lieu du procès joe biden a
également réagi après avoir rappelé la
famille de georges floyd le président
américain s'est dit soulagé par la
décision de justice
même s'il reconnaît que la lutte n'est
pas terminée rien ne pourra jamais
ramené leurs frères leurs pères mais
cela peut être un pas de géant dans la
marche vers la justice en amérique
soyons également clair sur le fait qu'un
tel verdict est également beaucoup trop
rares c'est le moment pour ce pays de se
rassembler de s'unir en tant
qu'américains nous ne pouvons jamais
être un havre de paix pour la haine en
amérique
derek chauvine doit désormais attendre
huit semaines pour connaître sa sentence
proche de l'implosion sociale il ya
encore quelques mois les états unis
évite une nouvelle décision de justice
controversée mais le combat contre les
violences policières semble loin d'être
terminée et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis washington avec terrell
ventura présentateur rt america c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir tel ventura merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france est donc un
jugement historique qui a été rendu à
minneapolis bâti de marquer un tournant
dans l'histoire des états unis
c'est une très bonne question
effectivement c'est historique
véritablement historique
ce n'est que la première étape est un
très long marathon qui passe par une
chaîne montagneuse afin de renverser le
racisme institutionnel qui existe dans
la justice dans la police et dans la
société en général aux états unis la non
de la culpabilité de langue slovène a
fait réagir de nombreuses personnalités
1 bill clinton barack obama joe biden on
l'a vu dans ce sujet qui est même allé
jusqu'à dire qu'il aime répandre la
famille de georges floyd dans ses bras
c'était étonnant aux états unis ce parti
pris affiché par des personnalités sur
une décision de justice ces réactions
quoi qu'on en pense à ne sont elles pas
politique
une question importante ce qui est
arrivé l'été dernier à minneapolis et
manifestations historiques qui ont été
organisées après de toute façon faisait
qu'il s'agirait un sujet politique
nos hommes et femmes politiques nos
dirigeants doivent refléter l'état de la
société
je ne pense pas que là le sujet a été
politisée je pense que le racisme a été
un problème aux états unis depuis très
longtemps qui nous a accompagnés dans
notre politique dans notre culture dans
tout ce que nous faisons donc
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient eu tort de
s'exprimer surtout lorsque c'est
intervenue après le verdict mais comme
tout sujet aux états unis la politique
s'empare du sujet bien sûr notamment
lorsqu'il s'agit de communauté opprimée
qui ont donc des bénéfices et des
inconvénients
alors ce n'est pas fini parce que on
attend encore le verdict qui tombera la
peine en tout cas la sentence dans huit
semaines ça va être également très
suivie très attendu à quoi faut-il
s'attendre selon vous seront peut-être
huit semaines très intéressant l'autre
l'équipe la défense de derek chauvin va
bien sûr faire appel
on ne sait pas s'il va vraiment devoir
purger cette peine qui arrive à y voir
donc des appels à la paix il faudra voir
le résultat tout cela il est important
de se rendre compte que statistiquement
en moyenne c'est un cas de figure très
rare un officier qui a été condamné et
qui va également recevoir une
condamnation une mois ben c'est très
rare depuis 2005 il y a eu 81 17 cas où
un officier de police s'est retrouvé
devant les tribunaux après une fusillade
et seuls sept cas sont arrivés ont
complété le procès il n'est que cette
condamnation
en moyenne les policiers au niveau des
statistiques bénéficient d'une impunité
car il y a à peu près d'après les
statistiques au moins 1000 fusillade par
an donc c'est un cas de figure
extrêmement rare et à l'avenir
il faut y aller un jour à la fois il
semaine à la fois et il est certain que
derek chemin va faire appel
il faudra donc voir ce qui arrive
ensuite merci beaucoup telle aventure à
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les incidents à
tourcoing dans le nord des tirs de
mortiers d'artifice ont été tirés cet
après midi encore sans faire de blessé
près du domicile d'un policier après une
quatrième nuit d'incidents et puis nous
parlerons de vannes eva faute d'accord
avec l'union européenne ce laboratoire
franco autrichien va se tourner vers des
discussions pays par pays pour fournir
son candidat vaccin
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
était arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il qu'on est
les impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés c'est impossible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les types de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 21 avril
les tensions ne retombe pas à tourcoing
dans le nord de la france des tirs de
mortiers d'artifice ont été tirés cet
après midi encore sans faire de blessé
près du domicile d'un policier près une
quatrième nuit d'incidents
si les forces de l'ordre ont été
déployés dans les différents quartiers
les troubles ont été limités sept
individus ont été interpellés
une start-up franco-autrichienne valnet
va bel et bien créer un vaccin contre le
pot vite sur le principe du virus
inactivé faute d'accord avec l'union
européenne
le laboratoire se tourner vers des
discussions pays par pays pour fournir
son candidat vaccin
dénonçant l'échec de l'europe les
eurodéputés rn publie d'ailleurs un
livre noir de la stratégie vaccinale de
bruxelles la gestion laborieuse de la
crise sanitaire qui donnent de la voix
aux eurosceptiques l'union européenne
n'a pas forcément fait la force et les
pays de l'union constate qu'ils n'ont
plus toujours leur autonomie qu'en est
il pour l'économique est la conséquence
aurait une sortie de la zone euro est il
un risque a retrouvé notre souveraineté
ce sera l'objet d'un face à face à nîmes
et entre deux économistes chevronnés
jacques sapir et marc touati
[Musique]
la tension ne retombe pas à tourcoing
dans le nord de la france à des tirs de
mortiers d'artifice ont été tirés cet
après midi encore sans faire de blessé
près du domicile d'un policier après une
quatrième nuit d'incidents si les forces
de l'ordre ont été déployés dans les
différents quartiers les troubles ont
été limités sept individus ont été
interpellés hier le ministre de
l'intérieur et ancien maire de la ville
gérald darmanin a condamné ces incidents
est rappelé que la république ne
reculera pas écouté ses réactions
d'habitants de tourcoing au micro de
nicolas qui fait et je pensais que
c'était des coups de feu en fait c'est
peut-être les pétards ou autre chose
mais bon moi ça m'évoque un
mécontentement il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas je pense qu'il ya des choses
qui vont exploser cette manière là c'est
irréversible et comprend pourquoi les
jeunes
paris s'en portent autant après ouais ça
doit venir du fait qu'il est peut-être
de tourcoing du coup ils se ils sont
peut-être trail de se dire que c'est un
natif de tourcoing qui favorise sa d'en
entendre parler c'est rare par contre
les bruits comme ça c est fréquent mais
à certains quartiers on entend souvent
des bruits moi je à chaque fois j'ai
peur mais vu que c'est pas très grave
mais là pour le coup on en entend parler
et c'est vrai que sur les réseaux
sociaux maintenant ça se diffuse
beaucoup plus qu'avant et pour en parler
nous savons avec benoît aristide ou
délégués du syndicat unité sgp police
dans le nord bonsoir benoît ares i see
you merci d'être avec nous tirs de
mortiers donc cet après midi on l'a dit
du domicile d'un policier quatrième nuit
consécutive d'incidents l'aide tension
ne redescend pas manifestement à
tourcoing vraiment ça on pensait que
c'était redescendu un petit peu puisque
la nuit précédente étaient un peu plus
calme
on avait eu affaire à des événements
plus plus calme que les trois nuits
précédentes avec des individus qui
étaient beaucoup plus dispersées moins
en nombre et cet après-midi
effectivement comme vous l'avez souligné
un tir de mortier sur effectivement
l'habitation d'un fonctionnaire de
police savait donc que les policiers
sont des cibles
pourquoi basse époque à tourcoing les
policiers sont des cibles sur le
territoire
maintenant quand on est des cibles et
qu'on est en uniforme
on va dire que quelque part ça fait
partie du boulot même si on n'est pas
rentré dans la police pour ça parce
qu'on est rentré dans la police pour
servir les citoyens et assurer la
sécurité de tout le monde
maintenant quand on s'attaque à un
domicile privé d'un frontières de police
là on est on est plus du tout dans la
même configuration
donc là ça devient c'est à dire mettre
sa laine plus que gênant et ça mais ça
met en jeu aussi la famille donc là
c'est plus pareil alors l'élément
déclencheur semble être l'interpellation
de deux jeunes à moto samedi soir mais
la maire de tourcoing avançaient la
thèse de la lutte contre les trafics de
stupéfiants qui s'est intensifiée dans
la ville quelle est l'opinion de la
police wedde effectivement on peut dire
que les faits se sont déroulés peu après
l'interpellation d'un individu
effectivement qui est tombé
en motocross alors qu'il était à l'arrêt
qui a été interpellé par la suite par
les crs s'en est suivi très rapidement
des échanges de jets de pierres et puis
dans la nuit a été agitée comme vous
l'avez vu sur les images que vous n'êtes
diffusé avec des tirs de mortiers qui
sont très à la mode actuellement
après je peux pas donner de noms plus
totalement faux sur le fait qu' on a
intensifié les trafics enfin sur le
trafic de stupéfiants on a vraiment
intensifier notre travail et il ya eu
des grottes saisi dernièrement donc
effectivement ça doigts crispés aussi
ces quartiers qui sont aussi connus pour
le trafic de stupéfiants donc je pense
que c'est c'est les deux éléments plus
le confinement qui est maintenant très
pesant qui a créé cette pension on a
entendu emmanuel macron dire sa volonté
de lutter justement contre ce trafic de
drogue
la mère des batailles at il dit il faut
s'attendre à ce que ce genre d'épisodes
qui ont lieu en ce moment à tourcoing se
reproduisent sur tout le territoire
alors que sa bataille pas s'intensifier
oui c'est déjà ce qu'on constate
puisqu'il ya une sorte de comme je les
lis vos confrères il ya une sorte de
mimétisme qui et qui fait en france
actuellement on voit très bien ça a
commencé dans votre quartier en banlieue
parisienne c'était dans la banlieue
lyonnaise
aujourd'hui à force d'intensifier notre
travail
forcément on a des jeunes qui commencent
à être tendues et puis mince et très à
la mode donc on voyait les tirs de
mortier maintenant c'est la nouvelle
mode et puis sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est à qui fera mieux
donc effectivement on peut s'attendre à
ce que ça soit dans divers quartiers
mais c'est aujourd'hui tourcoing ce sera
peut-être demain une autre ville dans le
sud de la france ou en banlieue
parisienne
c'est quelque chose qu'on connaissait et
quelques années notamment dans le
banlieue parisienne ya déjà vingt ans
c'était déjà comme ça des cons
intervenait quand interpellé quand gêner
le trafic
il fallait s'attendre à des représailles
les nus qui suivait aujourd'hui c'est un
peu plus fréquents le ministre de
l'intérieur en tout cas prévu
d'augmenter les effectifs de police 117
par exemple à lille qu'en est il chez
vous à tourcoing on en effectif le
stable de dire qu'on n'a pas eu de gain
effectif depuis la nomination de
monsieur darmana en effectif stable on
espère des arrivées sur l'île
agglomération puisque chose que j'avais
dit à monsieur darmana il ya deux
semaines 2 lors de sa venue à tourcoing
et halluin
il nous manque 300 fonctionnaires sur
lille roubaix tourcoing est
effectivement cédé ce manque d'effectif
au bout d'un moment ça devient pesant en
plus avec ce qui se passe dans la triste
sanitaires et les différents clusters
qu'on a essuyé aussi dans nos
commissariats c'est vrai que c'est
fatigant pour tous les policiers sur le
terrain actuellement et ses 300
fonctionnaires qui nous manque
on hâte de les voir arriver très
rapidement
merci beaucoup benoît récit doux d'avoir
été avec nous nous avoir apporté votre
témoignage en directe ur rt france sur
le front du coc vide le rituel est
immuable un conseil de défense sanitaire
s'est tenu à l'élysée ce matin suivie
d'un conseil des ministres aussi des
premiers effets des mesures de freinage
annoncé en marche se feront sentir la
pression spital hier elle est toujours
forte dans certains territoires
malgré tout l'exécutif entend bien des
serrer la vis début mai comme convenu le
point avec estelle fages
les restrictions devraient être
progressivement levé à compter du 3 mai
à commencer par la limitation de
circulation au delà de 10 kilomètres de
son domicile
comme emmanuel macron s'était engagé à
le faire fin mars lors de l'annoncé de
ce confinement hybride une levée de
restrictions qui devrait donc
s'accompagner de la disparition de
l'attestation de déplacement les
terrasses quant à elle pourrait rouvrir
à la mi mai là aussi c'était dans le
calendrier du chef de l'état gabriella
del le porte parole du gouvernement a
précisé que ce dernier restait la base
de travail le couvre feu pourrait lui
aussi être allégée doit-on le retarder
d'une heure ou l'établir à 23h la
question n'est pas encore tranchée
et puis la mi mai devrait aussi être
synonyme de réouverture pour les
commerces non essentiels et les
lieu culturel avec des jauges de
remplissage qui pourrait varier dans les
territoires en fonction de la
circulation du virus
nous pourrions être au pic ou proches de
l'être a précisé ce matin et gabriela
talent mais d'ici là levée progressive
des restrictions le gouvernement compte
sur la chute bien entendu des
contaminations mais aussi sur la
vaccination avec est cet objectif 20
millions de vaccinés ayant reçu au moins
une dose elle animait toujours est il
que le recul de l'épidémie doit être
confirmée car il est lent comme l'a
précisé le porte parole du gouvernement
je propose de l'écouter
ce sont des résultats positifs des
résultats encourageants mais je veux le
dire des résultats encore insuffisants
d'abord à ce stade l'épidémie recule
deux fois moins rapidement qu'en
novembre c'est notamment le fait du
variant anglais nous savons qu'il est
plus contagieux plus agressif chez les
jeunes est un peu plus résistant aussi
aux mesures de freinage qui sont mises
en place
ensuite la pression hospitalière est
extrêmement forte
des propos qui rejoignent ceux du
ministre de la santé dans une interview
au télégramme olivier ferrand qui
évoquait une situation fragile de son
côté emmanuel macron devrait détailler
toutes les modalités de ce déconfinement
dans une allocution à d'ici à la mi-mai
noter aussi que le premier ministre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et le
ministre de la santé s exprimeront deux
mains à ce propos lors d'une conférence
de presse prenez la campagne vaccinale à
présent une start-up franco-autrichienne
valnet va bel et bien créé avec 5
contres locaux vite sur le principe du
virus inactivé il pourrait être
disponible dès l'automne 2021 mais
curieusement les français n'en
disposeront pas tout de suite et pour
cause le labo vient de claquer la porte
des négociations avec l'union européenne
pour l'achat global de ces vaccins 4 ça
pique nique nous raconte l'histoire de
ce fiasco français vous souvenez vous
que le 25 janvier dernier l'institut
pasteur avait annoncé renoncer à ses
recherches sur le vaccin contre le
coronavirus et sanofi accusent des
retards contrairement à leurs confrères
allemands britanniques les scientifiques
hexagonaux
malheureusement pas réussi à élaborer un
vaccin mais si en fait les chercheurs de
la start-up franco-autrichienne vannes
neva ont bien remporter ce défi
mais la poisse de cette société de
biotechnologie dont le siège social se
trouve à saint-herblain en banlieue de
nantes a été peu commenté leur vaccin vl
à 2001 est pourtant entré dans sa
troisième phase d'élaboration pour une
commercialisation à l'automne 2021 a
mais pas pour nous pour nos amis
britanniques et c'est l'histoire d'un
véritable fiasco français qui se dessine
la start-up franco-autrichienne produit
en effet ces vaccins en écosse grâce à
un investissement massif du royaume uni
le pays lui a confié plus de 1 milliard
400 millions d'euros somme indispensable
à son projet 60 millions de doses seront
donc livrés aux britanniques avant la
fin 2021
le risque financier pour londres et est
grand puisque le pays ne récupérera pas
ses deniers
si les essais cliniques ne sont pas
concluants mais qui ne tente rien n'a
rien ou pas grand chose et c'est le cas
de la france nous devrons attendre au
moins jusqu'en janvier 2022 pour avoir
accès à ce vaccin franco autrichien et
c'est regrettable car il est un des
rares conçu sur le principe des vaccins
classiques à base de virus inactivé il
pourrait séduire une partie de la
population
rebutés par les vaccins à arn messager
alors pourquoi avons nous laissé passer
l'occasion en or d'être plus autonome
sur la vaccination
cette start up était pourtant digne de
confiance après avoir créé un vaccin
contre l'encéphalite japonaise et elle
est sur le point de commercialiser un
sérum contre le chikungunya en juin 2020
la présidente les républicains de la
région pays-de-loire christelle
morançais avait contacté la ministre de
l'industrie au sujet de vannes et 20
quel gâchis de voir partir cette belle
pépite ailleurs en tant que président de
la région des pays de loire forcément
avec est une une grosse grosse déception
et selon agnès pannier-runacher cette
ministre interpellé sur la question
la france a répondu présent nous leur
avons fait une proposition de soutien à
hauteur de 80%
ils ont préféré passer un accord avec le
royaume uni le directeur général de vale
neva franck grimaud évoque pour sa part
la proche holistique des britanniques
leur réactivité aux demandes de soutien
qui furent les premiers à sortir le
chéquier avant
8 2020 y aurait-il eu d'autres points de
blocage côté français certains évoquent
le fait que valve n'est va disposer déjà
d'une unité de production en écosse et
que le ministère souhaitait une
production locale
mais à l'heure de l'autoproclamé start
up nation certains élus ont du mal à
avaler la pilule on avait sous notre nez
une start-up que les britanniques ont eu
prise au sérieux c'est la démonstration
du small is beautiful
à la fin de la crise il faudra poser la
question émane une macro et à son armée
de spécialistes qui grouillent dans les
administrations qu avez vous réussi on a
voté il y a deux mois une loi de
programmation pour la recherche qui ne
sert à rien elle n'incite pas à la prise
de risque et ne permet pas un pilotage
étatiques dans des secteurs stratégiques
comme la santé un malheur n'arrivant
jamais seul valnet va n'a pas trouvé
d'accord global de vente avec l'union
européenne
après six mois de négociations
infructueuses la start up va négocier la
distribution de son vaccin pays par pays
et cela affectera le prix des doses
cette expérience en dit long sur
l'efficacité de la gestion centralisée
de la fourniture de ces roms organisée
par la commission européenne
et comme dit l'adage nul n'est prophète
en son pays ou dans sa communauté
mais justement le rassemblement national
publie un livre noir la stratégie
vaccinale de l'union européenne les 23
député européen du parti de marine le
pen s'attaque à la gestion de la crise
et à la stratégie vaccinale de lieux
la négociation des vaccins laisser à la
commission le manque de production et le
retard de livraison des doses commandées
l'afate de l'antiviral md et vire
également sur une trentaine de pages des
élus dénoncent ce qu'ils considèrent
comme des défaillances avec en ligne de
mire thierry breton chargé de la task
force européenne sur la production du
vaccin et emmanuel macron qui prendra la
présidence tournante de l'union en
janvier prochain et pour en parler nous
sommes avec jérôme rivière député
européen et rennes dont ce soir
rire merci d'être avec nous vous faites
de ses signataires et vous voyez dans ce
retard de vaccination la preuve donc de
la faillite du modèle de l'union
européenne
en quoi les t-il écoutez j'écoutais le
passionnant reportage que vous diffusiez
justement cet échange avec vous nous
avons sorti notre livre noir hier et dès
aujourd'hui on voit que des éléments
supplémentaires vient de démontrer la
faillite de la politique menée par
l'union européenne vale neva entreprises
françaises start-up pme et qui réussit à
développer en france un vaccin
on a vu par dogmatisme emmanuel macron a
choisi de ne pas travailler en direct
avec cette entreprise
au contraire du royaume uni qui dès le
mois de juillet dernier investissez
quand on parle de sommes considérables
il faut pas oublier qu'on parle de 100
millions d'euros alors même qu'on
dépense des milliards tous les jours
parce que le pays est fermée donc il
faut mettre ces 100 millions d'euros qui
était une somme importante en rapport
avec les milliards que nous coûte le
fait que nous ayons pas assez de vaccins
emmanuel macron par dogmatisme choisi de
ne pas travailler avec cette entreprise
dit il faut travailler que l'union
européenne et on voit aujourd'hui après
plus de quatre mois de discussions avec
valve neva est obligé de dire mais je ne
peux pas ça ne fonctionne pas on
n'arrive pas à avoir un accord et je
vais travailler avec chacun des pays
comme je lé fais avec le royaume uni
c'est un échec terrible c'est un échec
parce que c'est triste quand même que la
france qui soit l'inde est l'un des cinq
membres du conseil de sécurité des
nations-unies soit incapable de produire
elle-même son vaccin que la pme
la start up qui pourrait lui permettre
d'être de rentrer de nouveau dans cette
cour des grands pays de recherche
constate qu'elle n'est pas capable de
travailler avec avec la france c'est
extrêmement triste
et tout ça c'est lié au dogmatisme et
cette volonté de tout faire passer par
l'union européenne on vous parlait de
dogmatisme mais at on le choix quand on
a signé quand on fait partie justement
de l'union européenne est ce qu'on a le
choix de pouvoir s'affranchir de ses
partenaires
c'est une bonne question mais en matière
de santé effectivement nous avions le
choix parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
compétence de l'union européenne il ya
des domaines dans lequel la france a dit
je donne cette compétence à l'union
européenne à la commission pour ce qui
est de la santé ça n'est pas une
compétence et donc c'est
une volonté en dehors d'être été
affichées par un certain nombre de
dirigeants européens de dire on donne
tout ça là l'union européenne rien ne
nous obligeait à avoir cette politique
c'est simplement pour emmanuel macron
qui essaye d'être le meilleur élève de
l'union européenne l'occasion de dire
écoutez j'en fais plus que les autres on
va encore confié quelque chose de
supplémentaire à cette union européenne
et on voit là qu en matière de 2,2
d'achat le le b à ba d'une d'une
organisation communautaire c'est-à-dire
d'être une centrale d'achat l'union
européenne est incapable d'être efficace
elle a été moins efficace on l'a
démontré dans notre livre noir avec
l'ensemble des labos de qu'ils soient
qui sont dans le monde
elle a été moins efficace que le royaume
uni c'est une odieuse machine
administrative qui s'empêtre dans toutes
sortes de contraintes qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les urgences notamment les
urgences de mettre à disposition de ceux
qui le souhaitent des vaccins et cet
échec il est il est terrible parce que
c'est la santé de deux taxes français
2011 français qui est en jeu alors il y
avait plusieurs options qui s'offraient
à l'union européenne et au pays est ce
que c'est pas plutôt un mauvais pari
qu'a fait emmanuel macron parce que
cette ce laboratoire y en avait d'autres
événements qu'on a fait le choix et le
pari de sanofi qui l'a plutôt louper
c'est pas ça le réel problème
écoutez il n'a pas vraiment fait le
choix de sanofi non plus il a il n'a
fait aucun choix français il ay là il a
le seul choix qui les fait c'est de dire
je confie tout ça à madame von der leyen
présidente de la commission evans m van
der linde est venu l'expliquer à elle
s'est plantée il faut savoir dire les
choses
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons dans
une situation désastreuse et nous
courons après la cua visionnement en
vaccins nous avons besoin est le pire
des choses c'est thierry breton français
commissaire français qui vient nous
annoncer des fausses nouvelles tous les
jours il est démentie dès l'annoncé
d'une nouvelle par la réalité est encore
une fois cette annonce date
d'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne n'a pas été capable
de négocier avec valve neva et ce
laboratoire renonce c'est tragique
à propos de thierry breton c'est celui
qui a affirmé nous n'aurons pas besoin
du spoutnik vais le vexin russe qui a
causé des divisions au sein de l'union
européenne l'allemagne et l'italie
plutôt prompte à collaborer avec la
russie sur ce point beaucoup moins de
volonté du côté français ce sont des
divergences profondes de points de vue
selon vous entre les pays mais
exactement
en fait vous savez c'est charles pasqua
qui autrefois disait ce qu'une nation ne
peut pas faire pour elle personne ne
pourra le faire et la réalité c'est que
à l'occasion de cette crise de la
pandémie due coronavirus et de la course
à l'achat de vaccins l'union européenne
a fait la démonstration par l'absurde
qu'elle n'était pas efficace et des pays
un peu plus réaliste que la france je
pense comme vous l'évoquez à l'instant
notamment à à l'italie mais ça a été
aussi le cas de la république tchèque de
la hongrie la pologne se sont dit
qu'est-ce qui est disponible aujourd'hui
pour protéger les populations
on a un vaccin en russie qui semble
fonctionner on a des vaccins en chine
qui semble fonctionner on a des vaccins
aux états unis qui fonctionnent ils ont
dit aujourd'hui je vais demander à mon
agences de santé nationales de veiller à
ce que ce vaccin soit utilisé les
verrines de veiller à ce qu'ils soient
bien compatible avec les notions de
santé dont on a besoin et
m'approvisionner là le dogme et
d'emmanuel mâcon c'est dire non non tant
que l'union européenne n'a pas validé ce
vaccin je l'achèterai pas aujourd'hui on
court après les vaccins cc c'est très
grave ce qui se passe parce qu'en fait
c'est vraiment par up
encore une fois je répète ce mode
dogmatisme parce que s'il n'y a rien
dans la démarche des manuels macron qui
n'est justifiée sur le plan de l'intérêt
de la santé des français âgés rhumerie
sa ligne il ya autre chose qui frappait
quand on écoutait les députés européens
sur ce plateau c'est l'opacité des
contrats
est-ce que
vous rassemblement national vous avez
demandé cette levée voilà effet un plus
de transparence sur ces contrats parce
que il me semble qu aucun député n'a
plus jeter un oeil dessus est ce que
c'est normal c'est effectivement
totalement anormal puisque le rôle d'un
parlement qu'il soit national ou
européen c'est de contrôler justement
l'action pour le parlement européen la
commission et ils ont refusé de nous
donner non seulement l'accès aux
contrats donc on ne sait pas quel est le
quels sont les termes de la négociation
ils ont refusé de nous donner le nom des
négociateurs vous savez quand on
négocier un contrat c'est important de
savoir qu'ils négocient est-ce que
souvent des gens qui connaissent le
domaine pharmaceutique et ce qu'ils
avaient des intérêts particuliers dans
le cadre de ces négociations
on ne le sait pas ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui entache terriblement le
fonctionnement de la commission et de
l'union européenne et on voit en plus
parce qu'un certain nombre de pays l'ont
révélé qu'il ya des terrans des
différences de tarifs qui vont de 1 à 8
c'est à dire que certains vaccins sont
payés huit fois plus cher que les autres
c'est totalement abracadabrantesque on
pourrait à la limite se dire on étudiera
demain comment ça s'est passé
s'il y avait pas la santé des français
qui est en jeu mais aujourd'hui la santé
des français est en jeu il faut arrêter
maintenant de se mettre ce blocage de
l'union européenne merci jérôme rivière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france non le reste de l'actualité dans
la banlieue lyonnaise un groupe de gilet
jaune s'adresse aux passants pour leur
proposer de signer en faveur d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne pour
rendre les transports publics gratuits
objectif recruter un maximum de
signataires pour mettre les élus face à
leurs engagements
elle risque à valeo avec quentin
mauclair entre les étals de fruits et
légumes du marché de villeurbanne émerge
un chariot plein de tracts sur ces
prospectus la mention rick pour la
gratuité des transports en commun depuis
le lancement de cette initiative il ya
une dizaine de jours les membres de ce
groupe de gilet jaune villeurbannais
battent le pavé au moins deux fois par
semaine objectif obtenir au moins 15000
signatures soit pour cent de la
population totale de la métropole
lyonnaise
c'est l'idée qui porte et que les gens
comprennent assez bien donc on n'est pas
inquiet sur le fait que ça va intéresser
pas mal de militants
aujourd'hui on essaie de faire ça de
montrer que c'est possible de faire
revoter le peuple sur des décisions
concrètes et sur des choix de société en
fait pendant les six prochains mois
ces militants gilet jaune vont
multiplier les actions comme celle de ce
mercredi matin et organiser des débats
pour mobiliser la population locale une
fois l'objectif des signatures atteint
il compte aller interpeller les élus
locaux comme ceux de villeurbanne qui
avait inscrit dans leur programme
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne et
la gratuité des transports publics
quand on aura suffisamment de signatures
on va aller voir les élus de chaque
commune et en priorité ceux qui se sont
engagés sur cette question de gratuité
des transports et de rick comme à
villeurbanne par exemple
et les mettre face à leurs engagements
pour qu'ils organisent eux mêmes le
référendum ont un peu moins de deux
heures ce groupe de gilet jaune a réussi
à récolter une cinquantaine de
signatures pour autant si le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne est une
revendication de leurs mouvements depuis
leur première heure il n'existe pas d'un
point de vue légal
et ce même si certains politiques ont
déjà relayé l'idée du rich pour ces
gilet jaune rhodanien l'objectif est
donc double rassembler autour de la
gratuité des transports publics et
militer en faveur du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne pour faire
perdurer le mouvement gilet jaune est
resté avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la gestion laborieuse
des crises sanitaires qui donnent de la
voix aux eurosceptiques l'union n'a pas
forcément fait la force et moins qu'on
puisse dire et les pays de l'union
européenne constate qu'ils n'ont
toujours plus leur autonomie qu'en est
il pour l'économique quelles
conséquences aurait une sortie de la
zone euro y at-il un risque a retrouvé
notre souveraineté
ce sera l objet de notre face à face
donc quelques secondes avec jacques
sapir et marc touati
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk up nous sommes
au bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois que la france
était en 2011 demande pas un petit peu
non ah oui c'est tous les fromages tous
les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
avec les français ne savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
à très bientôt sur un terreau ans
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine
il nous emmène dans les coulisses de la
guerre contre le djihadisme au sahel
l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un big mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant une mini ferme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune c'était
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas noël ou blick
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la crise du coc vite 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière lippert mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vieille a une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser bien il
faut déjà à empêcher les ca vaut de
partir ou en tous cas alors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
l'agité pour tous ce que ça apporte aux
enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des gros poste
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs les écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
leurs familles on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse avec
difficile
le
[Musique]
21h30 heure française sous et les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez les eurosceptiques
reprennent de la voix en réponse à la
stratégie sanitaire des vingt-sept très
critiqués on a vu il ya quelques
instants
l'union n'a pas forcément fait la force
et les pays de l'union européenne
constate qu'ils n'ont plus toujours en
leur autonomie alors qu'en est il pour
l'économie épargne des français d'être
public taux de croissance quelles
conséquences aurait une sortie de la
zone euro y at-il un risque a retrouvé
notre souveraineté
c'est l'objet de notre face à face et
pour en parler deux économistes de renom
l'un contre l'autre et pour marc touati
jacques sapir bonsoir à tous les deux
bien venu sur arte france merci d'être
avec nous alors vous vous êtes déjà pas
mal affrontés à coup de tweets
interposés sur cette question des
retraites l'union européenne votre point
de vue tout d'abord à commencer par vous
marc touati vous dit si on doit sortir
c'est une catastrophe
pourquoi une catastrophe
le vrai enjeu encore une fois c'est vrai
que jacques et moi finance parfois on se
rejoint un petit peu sur le diagnostic
nous sommes d'accord la zone euro
malheureusement on n'a pas su gérer
c'est celle à la crise
évidemment cette pandémie mais depuis
bien longtemps malheureusement avant
même la pandémie nous avons une
croissance qui est extrêmement forte
donc la zone euro malheureusement on n'a
pas réussi à générer une croissance
forte à concurrencer les états unis
concurrencé dollars et c'est donc ça on
est d'accord le vrai enjeu c'est que si
on quitte fectivement cette zone euro
alors là ça sera encore pire pour une
raison simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui
prenons ce qui est en train de nous
arriver nous avons une dette publique
qui explose
et pourtant les taux d'intérêt sont
extrêmement bas que nous payons sur sa
dette publique
pourquoi parce que c'est la banque
centrale européenne qui achète cette
dette publique qu'on appelle la planche
à billets si demain nous quittons
effectivement cette zone euro nous avons
plus ce rachat de république par la
banque centrale européenne alors là
immédiatement les taux d'intérêt des
obligations d'état ont commencé à
flamber
et si les taux d'intérêt augmentent ça
va casser l'activité économique
l'investissement la consommation et
ainsi de suite donc tout le problème est
là un des auditeurs dernièrement une
émission qu'on l'a fait avec avec
jacques m'avait dit oui mais vous
préférez rester dans le titanic problème
c'est que si on est dans le titanic
on sait ce qui va se produire alors si
on sort du titanic on risque quand même
de mourir donc l'important c'est au
contraire dieu d'aller voir le capitaine
et de dire attention là le titanic il va
foncer dans je dirais les icebergs et
donc il faut dévié sa trajectoire donc
le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui il l'a si on
quitte la zone euro quand une fois il ya
eu beaucoup d'erreurs qui ont été faites
ça sera pire que par le passé et surtout
dans cette
dans ces conditions nous avons je dirais
d'une crise sociétale qui est là qu
extrêmement dangereuse
on connaît évidemment la nature du
peuple français pour la révolution donc
une révolution on sait quand ça commence
on ne sait pas quand ça se termine donc
c'est ça entre guillemets et ben non
rien d'alarmant pourquoi pas quitter la
zone rouge c'est tout à fait possible
aux états unis si on s'ouvre est donc je
ne suis pas en train de dire que ce
n'est pas possible je dis que c'est
possible mais si nous le faisons
malheureusement ce sera pire que ce qui
est en train de se produire à l'heure
actuelle alors jacques sapir vous vous
comptez c'est cette vision vaut mieux
sauter du titanic alors oui tout d'abord
effectivement avec marc touati
nous avons des points d'accord sur gérer
la description de la situation et du
bilan maintenant je voudrais dire une
chose
marc touati insiste beaucoup sur
l'ampleur de la dette
mais vous savez on a déjà eu dans le
passé des dettes similaires par exemple
en 1945 on avait une dette de plus de
160%
or nous avons réussi à réduire cette
dette alors bien sûr il ya eu la très
forte croissance de l'après guerre mais
il ya eu aussi des méthodes de
financement et des méthodes de
financement au niveau de la france
à l'époque nous avons nous avions le
franc et c'est bien pour cela on
éviterait en action avec la banque de
france que le gouvernement à trouver les
méthodes et les moyens de se financer
donc je ne pense pas que la dette soit
un obstacle
alors maintenant concrètement c'est vrai
que si on était soumis à une forte
hausse des taux d'intérêt ça aurait des
conséquences extrêmement désastreuse
mais il n'y a pas de raison que l'on est
justement cette forte hausse des taux
d'intérêt si nous sortons de la zone
euro est bien évidemment nous
reprendrons le contrôle de l'ensemble
des paramètres de notre politique
économique
et ce qui veut donc dire que au niveau
des taux d'intérêt alors de notre jeune
les taux d'intérêt en france
eh bien ils seront décidées par la
banque centrale française par la banque
de france
donc ce que fait aujourd'hui la banque
centrale européenne est bien la banque
de france le fera et puis par ailleurs
au niveau je dirais du besoin s'il en
est parce qu'il n'est pas du tout sûr
qu'on ait ce besoin de demander de
l'argent à l'excellent faut savoir une
chose aujourd'hui
au niveau mondial il y à un excès de
liquidités alors cette ligue
cette liquidité elle cherche évidemment
à s'investir dans différents titres et
des titres qu'ils soient si possible sur
comme justement des obligations d'état
alors bien sûr on dira l'allemagne a
plus de réputation de la france où il
est justement l'allemagne et m
eu de titre en fait en volume c'est
plutôt la france qui en est mais est
donc ce ne sont pas les titres allemands
qui seront suffisants pour absorber cet
immense réservoir de liquidité qui
existent au niveau mondial donc ce qui
veut dire que en réalité nous
retrouverons des 6 et si on en a besoin
et je ne suis pas du tout sûr que l'on
en ait besoin justement cette capacité
de financement à l'étranger après une
sortie de l'euro
un dernier point alors c'est vrai nous
avons nous français une tradition de
révolution mais il y en a eu aussi
d'autres dans les autres pays vous avez
il ya même eu des révolutions en
allemagne il ne faut jamais l'oublier
bon je ne crois pas que ce soit
raisonnable d'agiter toujours le pire
mais ça me fait trop penser à ce qu'on
appelle la stratégie de la peur
stratégie de la peur qui a été utilisé
assez souvent en europe
quand y avait justement des possibilités
de changement important et cette
stratégie de la peur elle a été
appliquée au breakbeat et sa échoué
donc je dis il ne faut pas justement
utilisé cette stratégie de la peur et il
faut regarder de manière raisonnable
comment nous pouvons sortir de l'eau et
on va regarder dans le détail justement
messieurs vous devez envoyer quelques
chiffres durant l'après-midi pour étayer
votre propos notamment ce tableau on va
le découvrir c'est une courbe de la
croissance de 6 pays européens la france
l'italie et 4 et en dehors de la zone
euro et la norvège la suisse le royaume
uni et la suède
regardez ces données du fmi de fonds
monétaire international je vous laisse
aller regarder alors qu'est ce qu'on
constate un que depuis la crise
économique de 2008 est bien la
croissance est moins forte dans les pays
appartenant à la zone euro
la coupe de la france et l'italie sont
en dessous des autres
les données du fmi montrent que ça
marche mieux en dehors de la zone euro
qu'à l'intérieur marc touati comment
vous l'expliquez non encore une fois le
lui le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui les
sessions si les voir qu'on fait souvent
parce qu'on vous dit si on quitte la
zone euro on va retrouver le franc est
donc comme par miracle on va dévaluer le
franc ont varié
orthez et tout ira bien c'était aussi
simple on offrait tout de suite bien
entendus le problème c'est qu'il faut
pas oublier pourquoi aujourd'hui la
france est à la traîne des nations en
termes de croissance économique parce
que malheureusement la france
indépendamment de l'euro est l'un des
derniers pays développés au monde qui
n'a pas moderniser son économie a on le
voit aujourd'hui par exemple l'allemagne
qui est comme vous le savez dans la zone
euro et une économie qui arrive
justement à exporter non pas parce que
ces produits ne sont pas chères ou
contraire les produits allemands sont
très chers mais l'allemagne cette
intelligence de faire une stratégie
d'innovation de garder son industrie
ce que nous n'avons pas su faire nous
les français donc tout problème il est
là c'est que pour qu'aujourd'hui les
français nous n'arrivons pas
malheureusement avoir une croissance
forte à exporter davantage parce que les
dirigeants de la france depuis des
années
ça commençait avec mitterrand en plus à
des résultats évidemment malheureusement
continuer on a fait une erreur
stratégique dramatique qui était la
désindustrialisation
ça c'est pas à cause de l'euro c'est un
sou un choix stratégique de nos
dirigeants qui était une erreur massive
et ensuite malheureusement on n'a pas
suffisamment investi on n'a pas
suffisamment innové
pourtant l'état fait qu'aujourd'hui
l'état français quand on regarde le
poids des dépenses publiques par rapport
à notre pays vers notre richesse nous
sommes numéro un mondiaux l'année
dernière on était à 62 % de pib de
dépenses publiques
c'est évidemment énorme voilà pourquoi
justement comme vous savez mais selon
des déficits permanents en france la
dernière fois qu en france admet un
excédent public
c'était en 1974 depuis que des déficits
donc c'est pourquoi la dette a augmenté
donc c'est là où on me dit oui ou non
demain on n'aura pas besoin d'argent et
évidemment comme en avoir besoin
d'argent ce que la dette elle ne va pas
s'arrêter si on quitte la zone euro la
dette va continuer d'augmenter je vous
rappelle que aujourd'hui même 52% de
cette dette française la dette publique
est détenue par des étrangers et donc
pour tous que ces étrangers est en vue
de d'investir chez nous il faut leur
inspirer confiance qu'ils aient
confiance justement dans une certaine
stabilité notamment au niveau de la
monnaie
et si justement reprend le franc je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il y aura une demande
mondiale de francs de francs suisses
certainement un mais deux francs
français ce n'est pas sûr donc c'est là
qu'est le vrai danger c'est à dire
encore une fois si on quitte cette zone
euro
donc je le dis et je répète c'est tout à
fait possible on va rentrer dans un trou
noir
je pense que jax l'a dit d'ailleurs ça
va créer comme des difficultés et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut arrêter
le déni de réalité un de dire l'an
finalement aujourd'hui la france tout va
bien si on avait une france ça aurait
été beaucoup mieux
non c'est une réalité aujourd'hui ce que
nous payons ce n'est pas l'euro je sais
que les dirigeants français disent
depuis des années ça tout est à cause de
l'europe c'est le bouc émissaire idéal
évidemment le problème français
aujourd'hui c'est justement les
dirigeants français qui ont été
incapables malheureusement de réformer
notre économie de moderniser notre
économie de réduire les impôts nous
sommes numéro un mondiaux des impôts ce
encore une fois c'est pas à cause de
l'euro parce qu'il ya beaucoup de pays
justement dans la zone euro qui ont su
baisser leurs impôts qui ont su
améliorer le fonctionnement de leurs
dépenses publiques et juste pour
terminer sur la france nous avons la
chance d'avoir un pays qui est
formidable
32 % de notre économie ce sont des
dépenses sociales
donc bravo c'est vrai que c'est génial
mais encore une fois le problème c'est
qu'il faut avoir aujourd'hui une
économie qui soit plus féconde en
création de richesses en création
d'emplois et c'est là on n'y arrivons
pas et si demain justement on quitte la
zone euro il n'y a aucune garantie que
on va retrouver comme par magie une
croissance forte des créations d'emplois
dynamiques
ce sera je pense pendant au moins
plusieurs années particulièrement
difficiles donc puisque le jeu en vaut
la chandelle on veut dire les on n'a
qu'à 30 et puis on verra bien je pense
qu'il est de notre devoir aujourd'hui de
dire on peut tenter mais attention c'est
extrêmement dangereux
c'est extrêmement coûteux et donc
l'idéal serait plutôt jeu de changer de
politique d'avoir des dirigeants qui
soit à la hauteur de la situation et
qu'ils aient le courage de moderniser
l'économie française et qui pourra comme
ça revenir dans le concert des grandes
nations
j'accepte finir justement changer la
politique la faute à ces stratégies
gouvernementales pour expliquer c'est
cette courbe un que l'on voyait
apparaître tout à l'heure vous êtes au
moins d'accord sur ce point avec marc
touati essayé peut-être de faire des
réponses un peu plus courtes comme ça on
abordera d'autres thèmes
oui d'accord oui volontiers alors
premièrement non ce n'est pas un choix
ont disons le feu ne s'est pas fait y
est de cette manière là le problème
c'est que nous avons eu d'abord la
politique du franc fort
c'est à dire que le franc a été
surévaluée et c'est ça qui a entamé la
désindustrialisation c'est la
surévaluation du franc
après cette politique elle a été
transposée dans l'euro vous savez
aujourd'hui si on recale culé le taux de
change réel de l'allemagne et de la
france il y aurait une différence de 40%
je dis bien 40% entre les deux donc
c'est ça aussi qui crée la
désindustrialisation de la france donc
on voit bien que de ce point de vue là
le facteur du coup monétaire des
exportations et des importations est
aujourd'hui quelque chose de tout à fait
décisif
hélas si vous voulez il ya toute une
série de rapports du fonds monétaire
international qui le montrent de manière
tout à fait évidente ce sont les
externats le secteur louis pop rock qui
ceux qui paraissent tous les hommes
autre point non ce n'est pas vrai que la
france et 62 % de dépenses publiques
43 8 5% je suis désolé marque
c'est ça la réalité il faut regarder le
reste non non ce ne sont pas des
dépenses publiques ce sont les dépenses
des assurances sociales csias système
assurantiel qui et c'est un système
assurantiel qui appartient qu ai je
dirais dans le cadre de l'état mais qui
serait exactement le même s'il était
privé d'une certaine manière les
dépenses publiques en france c'est 43,5
c'est pas 62 % enfin le dernier point
c'est que qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
on avait un franc qui se dépréciaient
évidemment le deutschmark lui
s'apprécierait en même temps qu'est ce
qui se passerait et bien toute une série
d'entreprises allemandes transférer leur
production d'allemagne en france
pourquoi parce que nous avons une
excellente productivité du travail
nous avons un travail qui est compétent
qui est de très bonne qualité
et si en plus nous avons des coûts qui
sont de 30 à 40% inférieurs aux coûts
allemand en raison justement de cette
différence de taux de change
et bien nous aurions une délocalisation
de l'allemagne vers la france donc c'est
ça la réalité d'une sortie potentielle
de l'euro marc touati n'est pas d'accord
du tout je n'en doute pas
non je n'y crois pas du tout parce que
encore une fois pourquoi aujourd'hui nos
propres entreprises françaises elles
vont investir à l'étranger parce que
justement on a trop de questions
fiscales
c'est comme avec eux quand il est libre
excitons à dire là bas tous les anglais
vont arriver en france on va créer la
city de londres
on va la mettre à eux à paris faut pas
rêver on va les anglais vont pas quitter
un paradis fiscal pour un enfer fiscal
comme la france là je pense du jack sera
d'accord avec moi parce qu'on va pas
chipoter sur l'egypte sur la dépense
pixelactive du fmi qui sont harmonisés
donc évidemment si on allait de
l'assurance publique en france et en
social il faut l'enlever dans les autres
pays
mais si on regarde pas con de point des
prélèvements obligatoires là c'est le
chinois aiment suivre pour tout le monde
nous sommes aussi numéro 1 de la planète
c'est la france que le plus d'impôts de
prélèvements obligatoires est donc c'est
ça aussi qui aujourd'hui fait en sorte
qu' on a malheureusement un coût du
travail qui est très élevé non pas que
les salaires soient élevés les salaires
nets ne le sont pas c'est que les coûts
globaux auto de serre qui sont là donc
même si effectivement demain on retrouve
le fond je suis pas sûr qu'ils les
entreprises allemandes ou anglaises ou
américaines
on va envie d'investir chez nous déjà
parce que on va perdre en crédibilité et
parce que ça voudrait dire que si
justement d'un franc qui se dévalue
cécile investir dans un pays et que la
devise se dévaluer va vous perdez de
l'argent bien entendu et puis
parallèlement le vrai enjeu est là c'est
que comme nous avons une pression
fiscale qui est extrêmement une verve
qui travaillent extrêmement rigide
faudrait te en plus si on a le front
faudrait un petit peu quand même
je dirais blizzard pourrait pour rester
poli pourvu du pool à investir
aujourd'hui en france donc
ou quand le vois moi je veux bien croire
au père noël mais on a aujourd'hui un
vrai danger sur notre économie française
indépendamment de l'euro et donc si
effectivement on ne modernise pas à la
rigueur ça serait possible si on avait
une économie moderniser là je vais bien
on m'interdit notre économie française
on a une économie française dynamique
est là éventuellement peut-être que sans
quitter la zone euro ça pourrait pas
faire trop de dégâts
mais si on quitte la zone euro et que on
ne modernise pas notre économie comment
voulez vous que des entreprises
étrangères viennent en france et c'est
ça le vrai enjeu
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui au contraire
il faut dynamiser notre investissement
dynamiser notre innovation et ce qui
permettrait justement à la france d'être
à la pointe 1 et non pas aujourd'hui à
la traîne comme vous l'avez montré sur
vos graphiques
alors il faudrait qu'on
d'un tableau en nous montrant la
composition du patrimoine des français
regardez ces chiffres de l'insee début
2018 le patrimoine des français est
constitué en moyenne de 20% de
patrimoine financier 61% de patrimoine
immobilier 11% de patrimoine
professionnel et enfin 8 % de patrimoine
résiduelles en clair jacques sapir c'est
l'immobilier est le placement préféré
des français en cas de retour au franc
quel impact selon vous une dévaluation
du prix de de nos maisons
maintenant puisque les maisons c'est
nous qui les achetons ou si on veut et
quand elles sont achetées par des
étrangers
mais ce sont des étrangers qui sont
situés en france donc d'une certaine
manière que la maison soit payer en
francs ou qu'elles soient payés en euros
elle a toujours d'une certaine manière a
la même valeur
et là on voit très bien une sortie de
l'euro n'affecterait potentiellement et
je dis bien c'est un risque potentiel
que la fraction financière du patrimoine
il n'y aurait aucun effet sur les autres
fractions du patrimoine et si vous les
jeux je reviens sur un point qui est
extrêmement important on ne me dernis
pas une économie avec une différence de
taux de change en sa défaveur aussi
forte que celle qui est inscrite dans la
zone euro
c'est impossible ça ne s'est jamais vu
dans le monde s'était jamais vu depuis
50 ans si on veut moderniser l'économie
française il faut tout d'abord rétablir
les conditions de sa compétitivité et
rétablir les conditions de sa
compétitivité
ça passe par une dépréciation massive de
la monnaie alors après d'ailleurs il
faut rappeler que une partie des impôts
que nous payons et on peut tout à fait
discuter sur le montant de la charge
fiscale
on peut considérer que ce montant de la
charge fiscale est peut-être trop élevé
en france mais il faut savoir qu'une
partie de ses impôts correspondent tout
simplement aux cadeaux qui sont faits
aux entreprises à cause de l'euro si
vous voulez les entreprises françaises
en afrique les grandes entreprises ne
pourraient pas survivre si tous les ans
l'état ne leur donnait pas en déduction
fiscale 60 milliards d'euros
sauf que il faut bien d'une certaine
manière compenser cela et d'ailleurs je
je remarque tout simplement que ces 60
milliards d'euros
c'est pratiquement la totalité du
déficit structurel français parce que si
on regarde le déficit budgétaire
français mais il se situe entre 2,8 et
3,5 pour cent marques ça tu seras
d'accord avec moi c'est sur longue
période c'est à peu près ça sur 10 15
ans c'est ça le montant du déficit
structure budgétaire structurel français
sauf que ces 60 milliards ça représente
déjà 2,4 pour cent du pipe
donc on voit que les cadeaux qu'on est
obligé et je dirais qu'on est obligé on
peut pas faire autrement de donner aux
entreprises du fait de l'euro ça nous
coûte déjà 2 4% du pib sur un déficit
qui est entre 2,8 et 3,2 donc on voit
bien que c'est en réalité l'euro qui est
la cause du déficit et qui est donc une
certaine manière la cause de cette
espèce de surcharge fiscale qui existent
en france
matt poitiers votre réponse oui il faut
juste ne pas oublier que ce qu'il ce qui
nous permet aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir
des sites trop haut trop élevé c'est que
les taux d'intérêt qu'on paye sur la
dette publique justement ont baissé
grâce justement à l'action de la banque
centrale européenne
je rappelle que pour donner un exemple
parce que là on parle un petit peu dans
l'abstrait mais il ya un pays qui a
voulu quitter la zone euro il ya
quelques temps qui s'appelle la grèce et
quelques années la grèce a voulu quitter
la zone euro du moins avant elle avait
pu les moyens de rembourser sa dette
je vais vous dire je vais vous des
regrets les taux d'intérêt à dix ans de
la dette grecque tenez vous bien sont
montés rozon qu'elle n'a pas voulu mais
disons que il y avait un risque
à une époque je rappelle que 2,6 prince
a été élu sur un programme seulement de
sortie de la zone rouge mais quand il a
vu ce que ça allait lui coûter il a dit
non finalement on va rester et il a
courbé l'échiné donc le vrai enjeu c'est
que quand à l'époque te ment la grèce
était malheureusement sur le point de
quitter la zone euro aurait pu bien sûr
un oignon on ne voulait pas le faire et
on ne peut pas te sont obligés à un pays
à quitter la zone euro cette émission
qui est souveraine
mais je sais juste que vous donner un
exemple quand effectivement un pays
était sur le
le point de quitter la zone euro ces
taux d'intérêt les taux d'intérêt de la
dette grecque se monter à 35%
quand cipra c'est arrivé au pouvoir donc
l'extrême bouchain finalement pour dire
on va quitter la zone euro
anglès et bien le taux d'intérêt pareil
à 10 ans il remontait à 20%
donc ça veut dire que si demain on
s'amuse à vouloir quitter la zone euro
alors bien sûr la france n'est pas la
grèce mais tout de même les taux
d'intérêt vont inévitablement augmenter
et là le déficit public
il va exploser il faut bien prendre
conscience que ça c'est un vrai enjeu
est encore une fois pour pour être très
honnête au niveau de la dette
moi la dette s'impose ça ne pose pas de
problème on doit tous endettés
c'est très bien cantonné à un ménage on
s'endette pour acquérir notre son
logement côté des entreprises on
s'endette pour investir pour innover
pareil pour l'état mais à une condition
il faut que cette dette soit soutenable
ça veut dire qu'elle génère suffisamment
de croissance d'activité de revenus
d'emploi mois pour rembourser les
intérêts de la dette et pour rembourser
les échéances
ce qui n'est toujours pas le cas en
france en moyenne sur les quinze élèves
année ce n'est évidemment pas le cas
donc voilà un problème
donc voilà pourquoi s'endetter très bien
au diable l'avarice
mais il faut que cette dette soit
efficace qu'elle génère de l'activité
si on s'endette pour colmater les
brèches alors là évidemment on n'y
arrivera pas et c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui c'est le qu'on appelle un
aléa moral en théorie des jeux ce qui
est très dangereux à l'heure actuelle
c'est que nos dirigeants ils se disent
finalement donc continué à lâcher la
dette publique ce que comme c'est la bce
qui rachète on peut continuer comme ça
donc là par contre c'est vrai que si
demain il n'y a plus la baiss e si
demain on retrouve le franc alors là
comme les taux d'intérêt augmentent et
on pourra plus faire n'importe quoi sur
la dette publique est certainement que
l'on aura moins de déficit mais
néanmoins l'enjeu aujourd'hui est là
c'est que cette dette justement comme
elle ne coûte rien entre guillemets on
avance et on met en danger je dis bien
on met en danger nos enfants les
générations à venir ce que qu'on croit
pas de cette dette va disparaître comme
par miracle parce que si jamais on
s'amuse à annuler une partie de la dette
par les taux d'intérêt sur la dette à
venir vont exploser et nos enfants
paieront les générations nous on perd à
une également nos enfants donc c'est
extrêmement dangereux donc voilà
pourquoi je parle de mois dernier à sion
de l'économie et d'améliorations
certainement du fonctionnement de la
zone euro j'ai souvent justement dénoncé
un quand la bce avait échoué en euro
trop fort oui l'euro aujourd'hui est
beaucoup trop fort qu'on avait cela
favorise et a constamment lutter contre
l'inflation alors qu'il n'avait pas donc
elle a cassé
la croissance donc c'est clair qu'il ya
eu beaucoup d'erreurs qui ont été faites
dans la zone euro je dis aujourd'hui
tant il faut corriger ses erreurs mais
si on est en marge de deux delà de la
construction européenne et surtout je
dirais que la marche de monde finalement
non le voir ce qui va se passer c'est
que la france va rester en marge et
finalement va sauter du titanic
alors peut-être qu'on n'aura pas l'asvel
iceberg mais on va mourir de froid quand
même dans l'eau donc tout l'enjeu
aujourd'hui il est là il faut avoir une
décision qui soit peut-être concertée
organisée pour mieux que l'euro pour que
leur fonctionne beaucoup mieux
ou alors quitter l'euro mais de façon
beaucoup plus d'ordonner mais si ça se
passe de façon désordonnée un pays seul
par exemple la france ça ne coûtera
extrêmement cher donc ça c'est c'est une
réalité tout simplement qu'on ne peut
pas aujourd'hui masqué et il faut
arrêter de déni de réalité c'est ça peut
être extrêmement dangereux pour les
générations à venir
jacques sapir le déni de réalité ça nous
coûterait beaucoup trop cher votre
réponse et le mot de la fin s'il vous
plaît alors très rapidement je pense que
le déni de réalité il est plutôt dans le
camp de marc touati jeu et que je suis
désolé de devoir dire ça parce que là
encore un petit prince n'a jamais été
saoul et j'ai été conseiller du vue du
gouvernement grec n'a jamais voulu
sortir de l'eau c'est d'ailleurs le
problème s'il avait voulu sortir de
l'euro la grèce aurait pu retrouver des
justement des marges de manoeuvre ça
c'est un premier point deuxième point
c'est une point qui est très important
c'est que les taux d'intérêt la question
c'est toi est ce que ce sont des taux
d'intérêts de marché ou est ce que sont
des taux des taux d'intérêt qui sont
fixés par la banque centrale par la
banque de france s'ils sont fixés par la
banque de france
il n'y a plus de problème et il faut
bien voir ça si la banque sans de france
rachète une grande partie de la dette
il n'y a plus de problème de taux
d'intérêt et comme d'une certaine
manière cette espèce de décrochage à la
suite d'une sortie d'euros 7
cette dépréciation forte de la monnaie
française par rapport à la monnaie
allemande va engendrer un surcroît de
production parce que jeudi il y aura
immédiatement des entreprises allemandes
ou des entreprises hollandaises qui vont
se retransformer en france en
particulier pour faire de la sous
traitance
d'ailleurs bon bah
on a ça on aura à la fois un taux de
croissance extrêmement important moi on
a calculé dans mon centre de recherches
il ya quelques années on avait montré
que le taux de croissance sur les trois
premières années d'une sortie de l'euro
serait située entre 4 et 5%
je rappelle que l'on faisait avant la
crise de la copie 1,5 pour cent de taux
de croissance donc un taux de croissance
fort plus des taux d'intérêt qui sont
contrôlés et bien on verrait que la
dette diminuera et là ce que l'on voit
sur le tableau c'est aussi extrêmement
intéressant
c'est ce qu'a coûté l'euro à l'économie
française
en fait il ya la courbe de croissance
avec l'euro qui a la courbe de
croissance réel qui est sont les données
qui sont calculées par le fonds
monétaire international
et puis avec des les collègues nous
avons re estime est ce qu aurait été la
croissance de la france
sans l'euro et on voit qu'il y à un
décalage entre les deux courbes
extrêmement important d'ailleurs je
rappelle toi y ait gagné rapide à ce que
je voudrais gamme le cee marque n'est
pas du tout d'accord et puis on arrive
vraiment à la fin du débat aura lieu le
25 minutes les yeux comment mais je
termine pour dire que ces calculs ont
été validés ils ont été visitées validée
par un institut allemand qui est
d'ailleurs un institut allemand pro
euros c'est ça justement toute l'ironie
de l'histoire bon marc touati n'est pas
d'accord mais mais malheureusement on
n'arrive vraiment la fin d'un de huy
juin knott non aller si vite
il vous plaît parce qu'on arrive à un
train d'enfer et vu que je dirais
simplement que ces primes des calculs
des économistes et toutes choses égales
par ailleurs ce qui n'est jamais le cas
moi simplement ce que je veux dire c'est
que faut pas détruire il faut construire
faut aller de l'avant et la destruction
peut être extrêmement dangereux devions
améliorer tout en construisant que
détruire en laissant croire que ça ira
beaucoup mieux ce qui ne sera évidemment
pas le cas merci à tous les deux marc
touati j'accepte fière d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce débat passionnant sur
l'opportunité ou non de la sortie de
l'euro en tout cas il y avait deux
points de vue
richer est différent merci à vous deux
et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes avec emilie goog h
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ça